e
okay yeah no 1264 should be easy okay um
going to convene the executive session
of the house election law committee um
representative Howard direct lead us in
the
pledge
she
okay going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 1264 FN relative
to the definition of accessible voting
systems I'm going to recognize
representative weie to make a
motion I'd like to make a motion that it
ought to pass is there a second all
second representative Howard seconds are
there any amendments to the bill yes
there is I have an amendment
representative we would you like to move
your Amendment yes I would like to move
that Amendment um 20124 1041 H um amend
the bill all right representative wor
moves H uh Amendment 2024 d104 1H to
House Bill 1264 is there a second second
representative Howard second we around
on discussion of the amendment is there
discussion on the
amendment this is a brief introduction
sort of reiterating what I said in an
email to the committee um Secretary of
State's office worked on this and uh as
well as forgive me um if I don't consult
uh I will mess up someone's uh name
um sorry
um
so yes so we had uh the disability
rights Center of New Hampshire the New
Hampshire Municipal Association all
contributed to this a lot of edits by
the Secretary of State's office to come
up with a short-term solution to uh meet
the more immediate need and it uh the
whole idea behind this is just we're
going to do a pilot program for right
now so that that will um allow the local
municipalities to uh install the or put
into action the accessible voting
systems and then uh in all likelihood uh
representative Paige and others will uh
submit a bill next year to address the
long-term
requirements further discussion on the
amendment seeing or hearing none uh the
clerk will call the role representative
fo
Yesa pom O'Brien yes representative qua
yes representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Bixby yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brandon yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
yes with that the amendment carries on a
vote of 19 to Zer we're now on
discussion of the bill if anyone like to
motion like to make a motion that it
ought to pass as amended representative
War moves House Bill 1264 should be a to
pass as amend with Amendment 12 with
Amendment 2024 d141 H representative
Lane seconds the motion so there
amended yes representative L I just want
to acknowledge how much hard work um
representative Paige representative weie
and others have put into this and worked
with the social this so God Secretary of
State's office and um and thank you for
your
patience yeah I want to Echo that as
well um we don't it's uh I I said in
child care earlier this week or last
week um you know you don't often get to
leave conquered and feel like you've
done some good um this one is going to
make me feel good so I'm pretty proud of
this thank you guys for working so hard
on it um with that the clerk will call
the role representative B yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative quae yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative viby yes yes
representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brenan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Raptor yes chairman Barry chair votes
yes with that um House Bill 1264 will be
reported out as ought to pass as amended
with a vote of 20 to Zer it has a fiscal
note so it cannot go on the consent
calendar so we'll see it on the floor
thank you guys um with that going to
close the executive session on House
Bill 1264 open up the executive session
on House Bill 1085 relative to public
inspection of absentee ballots
motion you've caught me off
guard
um
don't is it itm I would imagine that
would be
that would be itl okay I'm sorry I don't
I can't find my notes so yes itl is
there a second second representative
we're represent W seconds is there
discussion on the motion of in speed to
legisl and House Bill
1085 hearing none the clerk will call
the role representative B yes
representative pom O'Brien yes
representative quae yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative OS yes
representative cutab yes representative
lean yes representative Ward yes
representative Bixby yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
RoR yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
and with that the motion toed legisl
carries on a vote of 20 to zero House
Bill 1085 will be reported out as
inexpedient to legislate is their
objection to the bill being placed on
consent calendar hearing no rejection
the bill will be placed on consent count
representative Lane can you get me the
report um speaking that on 1264
representative weary can you get me the
report for 1264 absolutely thank you
with that I'll close the executive
session on House Bill
1085 um and we'll open up the executive
1239 um representative wood is
recognized for a motion itl please
representative wood moves House Bill
1239 being in expedient to legisl is
there a second repres anenberg seconds
uh we're now on discussion of the motion
speak to legislators there discussion on
the
bill yes representative
Howard uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you f committee members uh for hp1
1239 I know that I had mentioned uh
discussion potentially using uh the
language that I had brought forth in an
amendment to the bill uh in HP uh
1091 um I didn't know I know that we're
still working on that bill but uh as for
the reason for the itl is that uh kind
of because that's already being planned
in 1091 are we going to have further
discussion about this that that was my
intention excuse me um I actually do
like the concept um but that that was my
intention was this was one of those
things that's probably better swept in
there um if we can if we can agree on it
but you know as with anything things
happen but yes that was the intention
all right thank
you um any other discussion on the
motion of inexpedient to
legislate hearing none the clerk will
call the role on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1239 representative Bo yes
representative Pomo Brian yes
representative quae yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wood oh no representative
Wy sorry yes representative wood yes
representative Osborne representative
kutab representative Lan yes
representative Ward representative Bixby
yes representative
Mirad representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes Raptor yes chairman Barry
votes yes with that the motion exped
legislate carries on a vote of 20 to
zero House Bill 1239 will be reported
out as ined to legislate um I will
handle the committee report so I can
indicate that we're taking up campaign
Finance in a broader section is there
any objection the bill being placed on
consent calendar hearing no objection
1239 will be placed on consent calendar
calendar
calendar calendar sorry I had to take my
notes for consent calendar
um going to close the executive session
1239 uh burm have you gotten your
Amendment for 1523 yet from
OS okay okay all right I'll open up the
executive session on house house bill
1523 uh revising the Moder worksheet for
counting votes and elections
representative barnab is recognized for
a
motion um I uh make a motion to ought to
pass representative burn moves House
Bill uh 1523b ought to pass is there a
second I second representative wood
second is there are there any
amendments this amendment uh yes there
is an amendment which rep represent burn
would like to move an amendment yes I'd
like to move on Amendment 202
24-105 38 representative burner moves
Amendment 2024
d153 to House Bill 1523 is there a
second representative B seconds we're
now on discussion of the amendment is
there a discussion on the amendment yes
I would like to share some information
that I received last week after meeting
with the Secretary of State um along
with representative Hamlet we had
learned that um HB 154 is on the
governor's desk ready to be signed so
therefore this um
um this bill uh HB
1523 has another place um which is a
little which is much better than the
previous location uh since it does deal
with the clerk and the uh Ward clerk
there is now a pre-election certificate
that will be handled through the clerk's
office previous to the election and this
will allow them which they currently do
on Election net uh they they do an
inventory of how many uh absentee
ballots they receive and who gets them
and all of that this is just putting it
into this form which is then shared back
to the moderator and also later to the
Secretary of State's office in the
returns form so um it's just a way to
keep track of um how the absentee
ballots are processed and keeping
inventory on them
um so it doesn't really add much more
work it just has it the form is now
there for the clerk and just adding this
to that that's all and because currently
there is no inventory on absentee
ballots okay um further discussion on
the
amendment yes Ser Hamlet thank you Mr
chairman
um yeah so in House Bill 154 the
pre-election certificate is already
designed and it it uh does not include a
count of absentee ballots but the city
clerks keep a careful inventory of the
absentee ballots that they re receive so
um I mean you know that they receive and
then they they actually log them into
election n when they receive an
application for an absentee ballot when
they send out the absentee ballot to the
voter and when they receive the marked
absentee ballot back from the voter
so I don't see any any reason for adding
this language about the inventory of the
absente ballots in the pre-election
necessary discussion on the amendment
yes representative bar thank you Mr
chairman um although I can understand
why there may not be a need however um
that the work is already there
unfortunately we change clerks quite
frequently we have an election tomorrow
um we've now had in my Town we're on
possibly a third clerk in three years
there's so many things that these clerks
need to learn in a short period of time
and unfortunately uh what I'm seeing is
that some things are not being done all
the way through and this is just one of
those checks and balance for the clerk's
office just to say like oh I have this
form oh yes we need to keep track of
this so that way the moderator is aware
and if anybody has questions it's easily
found on the pre-election checklist um
if it's on the election net and there
are people that have concerns about
absentee ballots it's very difficult I
tried going on there you need an
invitation or a special email to to
access that um and I recently
experienced my daughter um followed
through with an absentee ballot and she
was not given an email so she could
track her uh absentee ballot wasn't even
aware of that process so I think there's
certain processes that are there that
are not followed through but with a form
that allows
um clerks to uh complete before
elections and process it through to the
moderator I think it will be very
beneficial to make sure that all that
information is being tracked
properly of Hamlet than you Mr
chairman
um I think
the the uh the new the city and town
clerks do get training and the Secretary
of State trains them there's also an
association of the city and town clerks
that according to the Secretary of
State's office this Association does a
lot of training Dean Healey is the the
um uh town or city clerk from NASA that
comes up here quite a bit and um he's I
believe he's the president of that
Association they do a lot of work
training the city and town clerks so
I still do believe that adding this
absentee ballot information to the to
the the the nice you know pre-election
certificate is just extra information
that doesn't need to be on there and I
have one more issue um on the amendment
it it says on letter c that the number
of spoiled ballots should be listed but
the spoiled ballots don't happen
until
after
um let's see the spoil ballots oh so
you're thinking that spoil ballots
are are identified by the city or town
clerk I'm are you asking me yeah I'm
asking you yeah so if someone had made
an error uh sometimes they'll they can
fill out that uh absentee ballot there
that's a spoiled ballot and they would
get a new one to I see I see okay to
make that
correction okay so I understand why she
has why we have spoil ballots in here
but I but I don't think it's necessary
and I don't think it's a good idea to
you know um CL clut clutter up this
pre-election certificate with the extra
absentee
ballot uh data all right thank
you representative weing yeah if I could
just ask a general question where where
else is this
information
captured uh you can find it on Election
net because that's where the clerk
processes it but I don't have access to
election net so I'm not able to get that
information ask a follow if you'd like
thank you thank you Mr chair so
um if this was on the pre-election
certificate then it would be General
more transparent to the voters at large
is that correct and and then they
wouldn't have to specifically go onto
election net in order
to understand this information and the
reconciliation of the absentee ballots
is that correct that is correct and
we're only looking at the totals of
these items so it's not like we're
looking at individual absentee ballots
so it would be transparent to those who
are interested in seeing the numbers of
absentee
ballots
of Hamlet thank you Mr
chair
um the we've found out since the
absentee ballots are tracked on Election
that it's very secure we know
exactly you know how many absentee
ballots were sent out and how many came
back so and I think
there maybe this is a weak argument I
think there has to be a level of trust
somewhere that the city clerk that you
know the information is in election net
and the public if they can't
see election net and they I think they
have to trust that this uh election
officials have you know there's a
there's a very clear and precise
inventory of the ab absentee ballots I
recognized Is there further question Mr
representative board excuse me thank you
Mr chair I just had a technical question
about lines 9 11 and 19 where you talk
about Ward clerk is that city clerk Ward
clerks are very different they only work
the day of the election there'd be no
pre-election involvement of them in
cities so I think the terminology here
is confused which is not anybody's fault
it's confused throughout the RSA I think
that's the existing RSA let me just
trust but verify that stat it is what is
existing and it's actually what is on H
out it's inconsistent in the RSA they
don't understand we would have to revamp
that whole section plus some but for for
sake of time just probably should well
I'll be voting against this as a highly
unnecessary am we'll uh we'll add that
we'll add that to our list of fixing
after campaign
Finance um so I'm going we're going to
vote on this today um I have sent this
off to the clerk the amendment off to
the clerk to get a ruling on gerain this
um I think it is Germain but it is
jumping into a different section of RSA
you're going from the moderator's
worksheet to the clerk's
worksheet I told the clerk I believe
it's Germaine but the last thing I want
to do is vote on this thing have it be
attached send it to the floor and then
have to pull it all off so we are going
to vote on this today we're going to go
into the AI bill but I'm I'm waiting for
a ruling on ger maintenance just so I
know so if we're done with the debate
I'm going to recess it um when we can I
just make sure that I explain it
correctly it was under the moderator
certificate because there was no place
for this however because of HB 154 it
opened an an Avenue for the clerk to
have a pre-election certificate so
that's where I believe the best place is
for it because the clerk is the one that
um manages the the absentee ballots okay
that's we'll uh we'll we'll take it back
when we come back we are going to come
back to this today we're going to come
back in a deposition on the amendment um
Z bur yes okay um so with that I'm going
to recess 1523 we'll come back on a
disposition on the amendment I'm going
to open up the um I'm going to open up
House Bill 1596 FN requiring a
disclosure of deceptive artificial
intelligence usage and political
advertising um representative weary is
recognized for a
motion I'd like to make a motion of in
expedient to legislate a second I second
that represent put Brian second would
like to speak to your motion yes um so
uh Judiciary is right now working on a
framework for artificial intelligence
and I think um part of that includes the
election um aspects and I think um it we
would be better served if we waited a
little bit I first of all I'm I'm
completely behind the principles of this
and I think it's a good idea I think
it's it's much needed um so I'm not
um castigating the the bill in principle
what I'm objecting to is is that I think
we've got another committee that is
spearheading artificial intelligence and
we should let them do their work and
then um as necessary
modify our legislation after they're
done their preliminary
work I'm sure representative Brennan
would like to speak to that thank you Mr
chair um the regarding the statement
about the bill that is in judiciary
there are actually several AI bills um
Judiciary is stripping the election part
out of the bill that they have before
them and in fact all of the AI sponsor
Bill sponsors have been invited to a
meeting this afternoon to discuss um
making some cohesiveness between all of
them um but the this bill would be the
vehicle strictly for elections whereas
the other bill
um stand on their own this bill as
written is able to go into effect prior
to the 2024 election all other bills
being considered by Judiciary and other
committees may not go into effect
actually cannot go into effect until
2025 I think it's really important that
we pass this legislation so that we can
have something in place prior to the
2024 elections um this is the only Bill
that is allowed to be passed um um and
go into effect prior to November 2024
the rest cannot because of the way that
they are written and they have criminal
and civil penalties um explicitly
spelled out and prescribed within those
bills this bill does not it leaves it to
the courts to decide what is the
appropriate penalty um while that may
not be the ideal um Bill this is the one
that provides the framework and allows
for for future bills to go into effect
in 2025 to be more prescriptive in how
they handle um AI related deep fakes um
and deceptive media
manipulation so I would ask that at
minimum um we consider passing this bill
ought to pass um and if there is an
appetite for waiting until after um
there has been discussion after today's
meeting
um to try and make the cohesion between
the bills um then I would ask that you
potentially recess so that we can come
back to it and potentially have um
language that works throughout all the
bills but again this is the only Bill
that can be passed and go into effect
prior to the 2024
elections further discussion on the
motion of next me to
legislate pres Lane
uh thank you I'd also just like to
remind the committee that Secretary of
State scalan actually supported this
bill and said it was a great first step
um and then we can build on it in the
next uh years to come as we get more
information and we're not quite so
rushed and I also would ask that we
recess and get Advantage take advantage
of the meeting that's going to happen at
12:30 and then either come back to this
today if we have to or take it up next
Tuesday
further discussion on the motion V speak
to legislate representative katam I just
wanted to point out that the same
section is also getting changed in the
Judiciary bill so these would be like
conflicting with each other um and that
one although they're still trying to
work on it today at 12:30 I think the
definitions are much more cleaned up in
it and it's
just the the legal terms in it are just
much much more clear I do understand
your concern about the the effective
date and perhaps that's something that
could be changed in that one but I just
I I am a little bit concerned that if
even if this passed today and then the
other one passes next week then it's
anyway represent Bron thank you um the
way that this bill is written again is
the it's the only way to pass something
in time for the 2024 election while I do
agree that the the definitions in the
other bills could be incorporated into
this bill and that is why I ask for a
you to consider a recess so that we can
get an amendment there were a lot of
developments that happened in the last
couple of days um in communication with
the other sponsors and the uh
development of this meeting happening
today um that made it impossible to get
an amendment drafted to make the
definitions match
as far as the other bills superseding
this bill would still be in effect prior
to the other ones taking effect so while
this bill may not um last in its current
form forever it is the only way to get
something done this is a bill that is um
widely supported and it is supported
emphatically by the Secretary of State
for passing it in this form um so again
again we can have it in place before the
2024 elections the other bills
absolutely cannot there is a rule that
they cannot go into effect until 2025
because of this prescriptive nature um
and the criminal penalties
Associated um with those bills so this
is the only way forward um and you know
again I would ask if you would consider
a recess that might be the ideal way um
to make sure that all bills are properly
considered if you would not like to
consider recess then I would ask that
you consider passing this bill ought to
pass and perhaps there might be a floor
amendment that could deal with um some
of the definitions that might come out
of the meeting later
today first question representative
qua Mr chairman uh I too have some
concerns with this
bill and they focus around uh lines 15-
18 on page one
and then lines 11 and 12 on page two
on page one line 15 uh if you read
through to 18 it appears to say that a
person shall not uh distribute one of
these deep
fakes uh who should have known it's
deceptive and
fraudulent and then on page two lines 11
uh lines 11 and 12 it talks about how a
candidate can bring an action for
general or special damages against the
sponsor uh it sounds to me as if this
would leave a person who simply
innocently distributed a message they
forward an email or share a Facebook
post they came
across
uh would then be subject to potential
Court action
for damages would then have to prove
they it wasn't the case they should have
known and I think the heart of the
problem here is that these deep fakes
are very difficult for anybody without
uh significant technical knowledge and
possibly proper software to determine
that it's a deep fake so in a nutshell
I'm concerned it could expose Ordinary
People to the risk of a court action
which they would then have to hire legal
help to defend against and and I think
that could have a chilling effect on
their exercise of their first amendment
rights I I have other concerns about the
bill but that's my chief concern If This
Were change to uh someone uh shall not
create and
distribute uh such a synthetic uh deep
fake file I think that would address my
main concern thank
you represent BR thank you um there is a
difference between a sponsor distributor
and an average average person forwarding
an email um and so you know it's
important to make that distinction we
have heard um
from
uh media companies who are concerned
about the
distribution
um mentioned in this bill and they have
submitted language for an amendment but
there have been other things that have
come across that have come um before me
in the last couple of days that would be
suggested language that we could address
if this bill is recess or again if uh it
needs to be passed today for a floor
Amendment I'm more than happy to hear
your um suggested language
representative qua and would welcome
that I've gotten several emails from
several different people several
suggested amendments and it just could
not happen fast enough to for today as
that much of that has been received in
the last couple of days and as we know
um OS doesn't work on the weekends which
is good for them thank
you further discussion on the motion of
any speed to
legislate hearing none I'm going to
recess this
bill um was trying to let you guys duke
it out while I got my Germaine ruling um
so we'll come back to this uh we may
come back to it today just FYI um so
you'll if you're leaving um
then you're not going to be enjoying the
public hearings in the afternoon um
you'll have to take me on my word when I
say that if we reconvene the executive
session this will be the only Bill that
we will take up um okay so we're
recessed on
15 996 um the executive session will
stand in
recess um because we're still waiting on
the gerus ruling so we'll start up on
the work
session
gears all right so G to open up the full
committee work session on House Bill
1091 relative to financing of political
campaigns um I believe representative
Lane has a redlined copy of the
amendment to the amendment to the
amendment to the r
clutched
think
e
at the request of a couple of people and
at the request of a couple people I went
through I don't need this somebody else
can have it um just to show every body
because the way that OS put this
together was to change the entire
chapter and there's a lot of sections
that are not changing so what I did was
go through and X out for you all the
sections that are not changing so that
you could focus on the ones that are
changing and when I get done with this
it eliminates about three pages out of
the bill yeah so there yeah so there's a
lot of things that in here that simply
when OS put it together they just
included everything including things
that weren't changing
so I thought at least that would allow
us to focus on the things that are
changing and you could look at those and
then a lot of the ones at the
end do show what's changed in the bill
so the last few pages of here highlight
in bold what's changing the language
that's changing and and take out what's
what is what is being deleted and a lot
of those are just to go through and to
um if you might recall rep
representative Qua we agreed that we
would put in keep in uh succeed success
what is it succeed or defeat or success
or defeat or whatever that term
was to replace yeah to replace the term
influence to support blah oppose
whatever so a lot of that when you go
back and change that that means a lot
that nothing's changing in a lot of
these sections the other one that's
being changed a lot is when you get into
some of the communication stuff it
focuses only on calling so we put it in
as communication again that's the only
thing that's changing is the word
calling is becoming communication that's
in push pulling and then when we get to
a section about um there one of the
comments that they asked us to change
was make it Treasurer throughout so it's
just treasure and Fiscal Agent so any
time the word Fiscal Agent showed up we
had to change it to Treasurer so that's
again a lot of these changes they're in
they're in here and they're minor but
it's not really the Crux of what we were
trying to do so I I would just beg your
Indulgence that's the way when you go
through a complicated section like this
that you have to do it but I'm hoping at
least you can see that the things that
are CH what's important and what's
changing and that was the purpose of
this I did give to OS today uh changes
based on what we talked about last week
because we're running out of time but
unfortunately I don't have that in front
of us for
today um and the other paining I held I
gave you are definitions that we worked
on last week that I cleaned up and
unfortunately um I wasn't I was getting
tired so it's not redlined but but but
it's pretty it's pretty much reflecting
what we talked about last week and one
of the things that we've talked
about and we probably should talk about
today is one of the things we did is we
conflated one of the comments we got was
that there is no definition of an
exploratory time a primary time and a
general time so and you can give but but
the statute says you can give like 5,000
during this time 5,000 during that time
and 5 thou but there's no definitions of
when those times start and end so what
the committee did was just collapse it
and make it one
time and so it didn't change the amounts
so you can give it to total of
15,000 during the election time and then
we defined election cycle but that's why
we had to also Define candidate because
it wasn't sure when you became another
thing was nobody's sure when you became
candidate because it says well you file
for office and the problem is you're
fundraising and Gathering money as we
all know during our current campaign for
governor everybody's out raising money
now but nobody's having to report it
because they have it technically filed
so the idea being that we would get you
can raise all the money you want you can
get it from wherever you want just be
transparent about it and so file it and
be transparent about it and that's
really what I think the bulk of what we
worked on was to try and go through that
piece and I know representative quy I
think you may not be no that was Senator
gray Senator gray is not in favor of
conflating it so we'll take that up in
the Senate when we get over there but I
guess I just want to have everybody talk
about that and give us your feelings on
that because that's what the
subcommittee came up with but if the
committee is not comfortable with that
idea then we need to talk about
ration um no I have not heard why I
don't recall one either this was by
email I think that we got that and to uh
agree with with representative Lane well
my idea of
having one period that covers the whole
election cycle but with the same total
donation is that I think it's reasonable
to presume that candidates and political
committees are competent to manage their
finances over that
period uh and and as far as
uh well the rationale for requiring
uh candidates and political committees
to report receipts above a certain
threshold uh I think the Secretary of
State expressed it very well he said the
point is to uh enable the public to to
decide for themselves whether someone
might be subject to undo influence by
say a major
donor uh and the the rationale for
having uh these entities report their
expenses is in my view is that it
ensures the public that those donations
are being spent for the political
campaign purpose but there's no you know
right just makes it more it keeps it
transparent that's what we do now and it
keeps it
transparent and I I consider that uh a
sufficient
reason the transparency in that with the
receipts and
expenses uh I consider
that
making sure the public can decide for
themselves if undo undue influence is
involved is a sufficient reason for that
compromise to what I think should be in
Violet that is the First Amendment right
to free
speech thank
you yeah and and so where that shows up
it's not specifically stated anywhere
but it shows up on page eight on line
four where it it talks about it
basically those three categories of time
have been deleted in that
section so it it it you have to kind of
know what you're looking for
that um you have to kind of know what
the intent was in order to understand
that change which is why I wanted to
bring it up to everybody so because I
don't know that looking through it you'd
capture that necessarily as to why why
it was
done and then another big change is
later down on that same page is about
Surplus campaign
contributions and this was something
that the Secretary of State asked so and
we talked about because a lot of people
don't um bring their accounts down to
zero as we those of us a lot of us got
letters I got a letter about you know
and if you don't do it there's severe
penalties and we um need to address that
so the way the Secretary of State
suggested doing it was to whatever is
left in your account at the end of your
campaign gets rolled over into a new um
campaign account so basically it saves
us all from being in violation of the
campaign Finance laws
unintentionally and um it will roll over
for the next year into a new account you
would have to bring that still down to
zero but in in the in the future but if
you're running again you're not going to
bring it you just have to file um so
that would keep a lot of us from being
in violation of the unwittingly being in
violation of the campaign Finance laws
repres to the next
campaign um so that balance becomes the
new balance
for your next campaign and if you're not
going to run then you you have to get
your that down to zero anyway so often
what people will do if it's been a loan
to themselves they'll pay that loan back
or that you can give it to another
campaign so a lot of people give it
to you know to the party to another
campaign you know whatever so and but
you would have to get it down to
zero also give it to a
charity yes
you need to get it down to zero if you
want to close that correct that account
out if you want to end it you have to
get it down to Zero by one of the
approved
methods the the excess funds from Barry
for governor will be given to charity
not to the not to the party just
saying okay and and then one of the the
other things that Secretary of State and
the AG's office asked us to do was to
synchron the reporting dates between all
different kinds of political committees
so we have done
that um bear with me it's on P page nine
and it starts um down at the bottom of
that page um where it talks about the
first Wednesday so this section is is
relatively new the wording it's some of
it's the same but some of it's new but
the goal here is so that all political
committees have the same reporting
schedules and there it doesn't vary by
different um types of political
committees and then one of the
definitions on this little p this page I
gave you was political committee um and
it reflects the changes that I think we
talked about but I would ask everybody
to maybe look at that as well
because it's much more simplified than
what's in the existing
statute and what happens is that if once
a political
committee um spends $1,000 or gathers
receipts of
$1,000 then they have to report so the
threshold is
$1,000 again you can take as much in you
can spend as much as you want assuming
the statute lets
you because some of these are are are
limited but just disclose it it's all
we're after is just disclose
it um and and to do it in a uniform
manner because they they entertain a lot
of questions SOS and the H's office
about when do I file how do I file that
kind of thing so um I
think that's
it and then the other thing about
reporting um is that we're going to
report by everybody has to report the
way it's written everybody has to report
using the um campaign
Finance program or system on the
Secretary of State's office the
portal sometimes I don't like to use
that word because people I appreciate
that not using the term thank you people
get have a knee-jerk reaction sometimes
to the word I I'm one of those people
and um we we phased it in with the idea
being one the secretary of state
is um developing a new
system and then two to have everybody
start using it the first year would
probably be a disaster so we phased it
in by having those um who have staff
basically and have the smaller numbers
so Governor State Senate executive um
coun members right those are the three
and then we would bring uh us the house
reps and the commi the Commissioners in
and anybody else in later in the second
year and um so that was because the I
the problem is is that a lot of people
in larger races do not use it and it's
very confusing and very hard to get the
data if it's not in the system in other
words if they they actually fact it in
they're still faxing their stuff in so
and they don't follow things by putting
them in alphabetical order and they make
it really hard for people to get the
data so the idea in the committee was to
try and do it this way and phase it
in so which I'm a huge I'm a huge fan of
that idea um because there are a lot of
games that are played with that um so to
representative Lane's Point you'll get a
candidate for for governor will fax in
like a 50 60 page report which is then
barely legible because it came in via
fax in
2024 um and then the Secretary of
State's office has to get it scan it and
then upload it and that takes a little
while so while everybody else has
reported and have their stuff posted the
campaigns that have decided to still use
paper in
2024 um are have having
their disclosures obstated for an extra
48 Hours um which is a problem because
we have a 48 hour reporting requirement
um
so that that's I know there's going to
be I know that when some of our
colleagues in the house see that there's
going to be this knee-jerk reaction the
online system is really easy to use it
is really easy it is easier than paper
like it just it just is so it's
2024 we can report these things online
the other nice part about it is it
becomes night and day did you have your
reported on time there's no like I used
to play a game I'd email it in at 1159
because the law says that day so I'd
schedule it up it would hit at 1159 um
so you can't play those games when
you're using online because it's just
did you make it yes or no um and it's
much I don't even I don't like fair but
it's much more um transparent and it
doesn't I don't think it imp on anyone's
First Amendment right to send a fact
like I'm sorry just not a thing so I'm
very happy that's in there I have some
uh Mr chairman are we following normal
rules of procedure where I need to be
recognized first if it gets out of
control yes but it hasn't so no so more
like the rules we had on the
subcommittee okay I do have some
reservations about making the use of the
automated online system mandatory for
everyone I have two concerns one I do
think it will it will encounter more
opposition in the house and we need to
get it past the house and I'm
also uh somewhat concerned that it could
be an additional barrier to
participation
for candidates for for the house in
particular who are running very lowcost
campaigns I think this could be fixed by
I'm putting this thought out here I
think this could be fixed by putting a
dollar threshold on
expenses expenditures and receipts for
when you have to use the online system
that's just that's my thought I mean we
could keep it the same as is now as
$1,000 thousand like you know so I I I
think that would be moot because if it's
$1,000 doll to follow to begin with I
would make it a bit higher than that you
think I I guess I can't believe I'm to
say this I I I thought $1,000 for a
state prep was not a lowcost campaign
some State prep put a lot less than that
yes yeah I I know I'm not an expert in
this but I um I run a lowcost campaign
uh and I strive to keep my campaign
expenses under $500 if at all possible
and uh I think that and when at the
point there was one point where I think
the threshold was lower and I used the
Secretary of State's system which was at
that point not it was not an ideal
system but it was certainly not terribly
problematic and it was a lot easier than
like messing with envelopes or faxes or
anything it was it was just like you put
it into the Right Slots on the on the
web page and you're done yeah my
favorite part about it is it keeps your
donor L populated so if like somebody
gives you another contribution you can
just click on it and it just
automatically populates that all that is
that is I cannot tell you how convenient
that is not having to go and look up the
same person 19 times I I like the system
myself I found it pretty straightforward
yeah well that's why I think it's
important we do phase it in um I hear
the concern um but I
think I mean I I I I guess an easy
counter punch is is how many of our
members are actually having how many how
many members do we have that are getting
the physical calendar mailed to them
because they don't use the internet and
are also running campaigns over
$1,000 I would imagine that number would
be zero um I do know that there are a
couple of members that get the calendar
mailed to them like that's the thing
like you have that option as a State Rep
you can get the calendar mailed to you
if you choose to um well I I did get it
mailed to me because I don't want to
print out 75 pages on my printer but the
difficulty with that is it takes six
days to get to me so I'll probably get
this week's on Thursday you'll enjoy
you'll enjoy enjoy finding out what
enjoy finding out what you just voted on
out representative B yeah it must be
yeah don't care yeah I agree I mean I
don't mail anything I mean I don't I
tell my dentist I don't buy stamps so
you have to wait to my next appointment
to get my money but the point is it's
the same online is easy it's it's what
but the thing is and I don't spend any
money on my campaigns I mean other than
when I ran for Senate but I had a file
but I mean I bought my signs years ago
and I haven't spent any money for
forever type thing so and I don't take
money from people and I don't spend
money so you know the county spends
money for me but that's their
problem
so I have the other situation where I
think I'm one of the like highest
spending State reps think I'm like yeah
but that's what happens when you
represent Manchester
and I'm the proud representative of the
chairman of the democratic party and I'm
sure he's I'm sure he loves my voting
and and you have a floal and I have I
have a 30,000 float I have a huge seat I
a huge competitive I have a huge seat I
think it's the 15th most competitive
seat in the state um and I'm a I'm a
Target but representative
Lane um to to look at representative
qu's um concerns one thing that I
remember seeing when I was reading some
different statutes where they were
transitioning into this is that if you
needed assistance or you didn't want to
do this that you could get a waiver from
the Secretary of State's office and it
also required them and and I don't know
if any of you but I've they're wonderful
to help you because I had so I don't
know if we put something like that in to
help the folks that you know for like
maybe the first three or four years to
kind of transition in if that would um
appease that and make it more yeah I
think that sounds yeah just just
some some way that people are going to
have a real difficulty with it but
aren't spending you know huge amounts I
mean you you and I discussed this uh and
I think we agreed that it's the the big
money races that are the most concerned
and they would they are I think and
should be of the most concern to the
public yeah I think starting off with
Senate council governor and Pax is the
way to go and then and and a a waiver
would be would be simple too and yeah
not complicate things it would be nice
like you have to explain why you want to
waiver like I cannot use have the
Internet it's like okay do you want
people knowing that
like but I think that's a reasonable way
to deal with that concern okay I think
that's fine I if that if that keeps you
said I would like to eventually move to
a system where it's you have to report
it online because it's just it's just
getting out of it's it's I mean it's
rampantly abused it's just rampantly
abused and it's not it's not driving any
compelling interest to keep it like that
so all right we want to continue on
representative Lane as we wait for our
uh apparently we're about to get a
ruling any minute now on the geras any
minute I know you are waiting with
baited
breath one other thing that we defined
was election cycle and we went um around
and around about the exact dates but
right now you'll see that it starts um
an election cycle starts the day after
the
election it's in a I'm sorry it's a
definition
I don't know if I changed it or not hold
the it's on page six it's line
three and what we we kind of tossed
around a lot of different ideas but now
we've come to that it begins I'm sorry
it's on the eighth day after a state
election through seven days after the
next state general election so the idea
was to capture that whole time period
and um the de the debate about when
exactly it starts and stops was that you
might want some time to kind of clean up
that and people might give you money
that you that you haven't put in yet and
whatever and to cut it off pretty soon
and um and then at that point then
you're running for your next
whatever election it is so I just
thought people should see that because
that is a at least I thought was a big
change we but we need to Define what
election cycle is so that we know how
when the time period is that people can
give money to because we don't really
have that
defined so I don't know if people have
thoughts on that I know um
representative Barry um wanted some I
think you wanted an additional time or
yeah I mean I'm not I'm not I'm not
gonna die on the hill but yeah know it's
I I I think I wanted it after the re I
think I basically wanted certification
um after the recounts and everything but
I think this is I
I'm it's not going to be like you must
do this or I will not vote for it's not
that sort of deal um but that that was
that was in my mind like once the
elections certified and over then it's
over because you still have recounts and
stuff like that and um but I said it's
not that's just an idea it's not a it's
not a line of the
sand well I guess in that sense will you
be you will be expending money at that
point so and it would be for that
election yeah that was my thought
process on it was that the recounts can
take up to two weeks
um you know and if you're in theory
hiring an attorney that sort of stuff um
right that would be so you want to say a
eight days after the election is
certified you you could do to me the day
the election certified it's fine
whatever you want it's fine I said I'm
not well I think this was the
recommendation of Secretary State and
then we talked about it in the committee
so I just want to make sure everybody's
got a consensus so that you know it
doesn't come up in yeah if you want to
do eight days after certification I
think that's that seems
reasonable
um yes represent rapor um yeah just a
question would that mean that different
Races end on different times if if a
race is certified yeah that's a good
point two days
after mean so would it be better to say
three weeks after the election because
we know that everything will be
that that's fine that's a good
point yeah let's just do three weeks
call it a day I think that I think
that's fine too the important point is
to have it clearly defined yeah yeah
have have a yeah that that's I'm more
I'm more concerned about that point than
I am anything else is the actual I said
this point in the
committee right there needs to be an end
there has to be at some point it has to
come to a
stop
um
um okay uh speaker says it is fine so
we're gonna we're gonna get out of
campaign Finance mode real quick do we
have everybody here um who are we
missing we're missing representative
Howard
um did he did he run the okay
he yeah can you somebody text him I my
phone or just send one of yours to the
back yeah we can do that or I won't yeah
there we go I'll tell you what we'll
we'll open her up while who went out to
go get
him get no somebody just went out to go
get him can I choose which one of yours
goes to the bathroom well you can go too
you know you can go get him and be fine
no all right we're going to to recess
the working session we're going to
reconvene the executive session um we're
on Bill
1523 me get to
my can I just make one comment yeah oh
yeah we're not We're Not Gonna I'm gonna
give representative Howard a second to
okay johnon back yes you you may speak
so we're on we're on 5023 we're on the
amendment um and we're in
a OT we're in it we're on the amendment
with an OTP disposition okay all right
all right representative bam you're
recognized thank you Mr chairman so I
just wanted to give you a visual I know
this is really far I don't have a I
don't have any of these for you but this
is the new updated moderator certificate
which is the where originally this bill
was intended to have the absentee ballot
inventory and you could see it's two
sides and they changed it so the totals
are on the back side for quickly
this is now just the moderators this is
the new revised moderator certificate
now called the pre-election certificate
which is to the clerk so it's not to the
moderator anymore and all this amendment
information the little list of numbers
that are is on that Amendment could just
go right on the back just for Quick
Glance so it's really easy and simple
and available for public to see if
needed I just wanted
that's what it's pertaining to further
discussion on the
amendment
um R zberg would you like to be the guy
that goes finds representative Howard so
we
can
okay I just just want want to notice
that the very niess I'm being here I
could call this vote here I just want to
note it when they right right write
Tales of my
generosity it's the most generous chair
of all time time and the most partisan
Committee of all
time that's right yeah this you know
people when people like when they pick
me for Governors they're going to be
like I remember when he held that vote
open to let his opposition come back
representative Hamlet I do have a one
more comment about
1523 on the amendment on the amendment
yes I'm yeah still not sure about the
amendment but I wanted to say that um
when we met with the secretary of state
office they made it clear that the um
the count Counting of the regular
election day ballots is completely
different from the handling of the
absentee ballots it's a completely
different process the absentee ballots
are sent out to the city clerks before
the regular ballots
and then the city clerks you know track
you know they track how many
applications you you know like I
explained
[Music]
um
and in fact the city clerk could could
mail out I
don't this could get really confusing
but I believe the city clerk could if
they mailed an absentee ballot to a
voter and the voter called up and said
they lost it the clerk had send out a
second absentee ballot
to that voter but it would be not noted
in election net that two ballots were
sent out to that voter so that if that
voter tries to vote twice twice that
will immediately be caught by the city
clerk when when the ballots are received
back so the absentee ballot inventory is
just
I I don't know it's a little bit non-
gerain to to what I was
what is it 154 it's trying to do which
was to uh you know clean up the the
pre-election certificate and the
moderators postelection certificate
which they are nicely cleaned up right
now and it also addressed the um New
voting
machines
so I understand what what the sponsor is
is trying to do with you know helping to
assure all the all the voter all the
people that are questioning you know the
uh validity of the um inventory of the
ballots you know I understand that she's
trying to do that but I don't think it's
necessary on this
all yes representative Burnham thank you
chairman yes so
this this is a new form established by
HB 154 and if it's signed in then only
then can this amendment take effect
there is no other form or access except
for online through election n by the
clerk to um see the inventory of
absentee ballots um so I just uh I think
that it just allows more transparency
for our voters uh to
see how many absentee ballots are
received how many are released to those
requesting them how many actually come
back because some voters may not send
them back um how many might be spoiled
it might be a small number but as we
continue to use more and more absentee
ballots I think it would be very
important to have this ahead of time so
if there's any question by voters um
it's a it's a quick view on one sheet
that's all together given to uh the
moderator and the Secretary of State's
you representative
Hamlet um so I think if we pass this
amendment I think we're actually
amending House Bill 154 no okay so I've
let this go 154 is signed into law so it
is now law right so we're not attaching
to 154 it is now chaptered RSA
it's a thing so this certificate exists
it is a thing now um so it's not if it's
signed into law it's law yes so it's not
it's not an attachment to 154 the RSA
now exists this is a are we going to
change the RSA that was in 154 that
became law are we going to now attach
certificate
okay do that clarify everything for
everybody 154 is law I tried not to talk
about 154 but 154 is law the universally
loved
um any other discussion on the
amendment um I will end with this I'll
be voting for the amendment I will
remind
um the committee I have voted for many
amendments that I disagree with in the
interest of moving things forward for
the other side so I would appreciate
some difference on that even if you you
do not even if you have fundamental
disagreements with the underlying bill
or even the bill as amended um but
that's all I can say to that with that
the clerk will call the role on the
amend on Amendment let me read out the
amendment number um
53h is it 1 Z1 it's one Z one
z53 uh representative fo yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward no
representative
Hamlet no representative Mirad yeah
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative
Howard yes representative Raptor
chairman Barry chair votes chair votes
yes I'm GNA need the count here 18 to2
so with that
Amendment 18-2 Amendment 2024 d01 153h
is adopted to house bill 1523
representative Burnham is recognized for
a new
motion excuse me what was the vote
you you recognize representative
burner make a motion because I I believe
you like to a to pass it Amendment B yes
thank you Mr chairman sorry I make a
Amendment I'll help I didn't have it in
Fr me I believe representative I believe
representative bam is is moving ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 1523 with
Amendment 2024 J
0153 thank you yes yes and
representative weary is seconding the
motion that representative Burnham
definitely made um with that now we are
on a discussion on the bill as amended
is there a discussion on the bill as
amended yes representative aenar so I I
just have a question about when the the
new bill when this form would be
completed
uh well it says oh oh like when it would
be completed or when it would become
law when it would be completed in the
election process representative Burnham
you want to answer
that is in other words is this before um
the polls
open oh yes uh this so the the
pre-election certificate is completed
before the election by the um clerk
yes
there yes sorry representative
Mirad that question um the original 154
now law it says when the ballots are
counted the moderator and Kirk shall um
certify the number received and here it
says when the ballots and absentee
ballots are counted now does that mean
when the unmarked ballots are counted
prior to voting day or does that mean
when the marked ballots are counted
done it means unmarked means the
representative Hamlet's answering
ballots
that sent by the Secretary of State to
the city and town clerks those uncounted
those are the uncounted
ballots uncounted okay and represent
head recognized and and what what point
like in the existing pre-election
certificate when would it says when the
ballots are counted the moderator and
clerk shall certify thereon the total
number of ballots received when would
that certification happen as 154 is
currently written and
legislated let's look oh it can happen
at the beginning of the
election
unless unless absentee ballots are
included if absentee ballots are
included we we still receive some
absentee ballots during election day so
on yeah believe that's correct and I
have I have another comment after him oh
represent sorry I'm I'm trying to trying
to read yes represent M okay thank you
um if we had to wait until all the
voting was done to make sure that no
election absentee B received on voting
day this would no longer be a
pre-election
certificate representative Burnham
actually um that those numbers are
counted on the moderator's worksheet and
that was already pre-existing this is
just counting the B the absentee ballets
that are sent to the clerk's office um
that are requested by voters okay that
closes the Friday prior to elections the
number of absentee ballots spoiled that
would be the ones if the voter uh makes
an error on their ballot and goes back
for a second ballot that would be a
spoil ballot prior to election the
number of absentee ballots not returned
by voters that would be even taken that
would be by that Friday or
um the uh prior to the election so th
those numbers would be there um and then
the number of absentee ballots not used
and that would be that Friday prior to
elction
ction okay so I'm going to read RSA
65832 from s SP 154 so we're all on the
same
page pre-election certificate the
Secretary of State shall prepare and
distribute to each town or Ward clerk
three copies of the pre-election
certificate when ballots are counted the
moderator and clerk shall certify
thereon the total number of ballots
received one copy shall be retained by
the moderator for his or her records one
copy shall be retained for the clerk for
his or her records and one copy shall be
forwarded by the clerk to the secretary
of state with the election return with
mhe you just looking at the way it's
written it doesn't I don't think it says
that this these numbers not returned by
voters for instance um line 16 on the
amendment would be not returned as of
the Friday before the election you know
at 5:00 p.m. or no or what have you it
could be you know that's open to
interpretation so some might think well
that's the number not returned at the
point at which all ballots have been
counted on on Election
Day I believe that is in an RSA I just
don't have that number in front of me as
to uh the process and procedures of the
um Clerk and the absentee ballots but
there there is a a date where they can
no longer mail absentee B ballots and
then the latest um they can receive them
is 5:00 on Election Day so um they could
still re receive them on Monday prior
but they we're talking about mailing and
there and there is an RSA that does um
have those if anything I believe it's in
the
workbook representative H thank you Mr
chair so then I think now we have two
totals of absentee ballots we have the
absentee ballots on the moderator's
certificate if we put in this amendment
that were received as of the Friday
before election and then we have the
additional absentee ballots that are not
included in that total that are received
maybe over the weekend and received on
Election Day
so so we have two different two
different totals of absentee ballots and
I have a completely different question
about this bill that is that the
original Bill
also changes the Moder the moderators
worksheet which is now called the
moderators post elction
certificate which actually is the
reconciliation of the of the votes at uh
on Election Day so this uh um so this
bill 152 3 would also change the
moderator's post selection certificate
against yes
representative you um I'm going to be
voting against the bill primarily
because I'd like to give a chance for
the dust to settle on HB
154 and then let's look at this to see
see if this is a problem or if because
we haven't even gone through an election
cycle with
154 in place and just not that this may
not be warranted and it may give more
transparency we just like to get a
little more comfortable with the new
process under
154 and then come back and see if we
need to do this and maybe clear up some
of the language that's creating the
conversation and confusion thank you
yes representative Burnham thank you Mr
chairman so the moderator postelection
certificate
only um has the numbers of absentee
ballots cast on as official election day
ballots and also the ones that are cast
on Election Day has nothing to do with
the ones the inventory that is being
tracked on the pre-election certificate
so they wouldn't even match it's just
it's
just monitoring the amount of absentee
ballots that come in how many come back
and so forth so it wouldn't have
anything to do with the moderator's
worksheet now because of this new form
154 okay so I think let's clear up some
of the confusion here the problem is is
the name pre-election certificate's
really
confusing it really probably shouldn't
be called that um we're not going to get
into that because when you look at it it
says when the Bots are counted so that's
not before the election that's kind of
immediately afterwards um so probably
should be called the post elction
certificate oh you're talking about the
physical counting of the blank ballot
yeah okay right Mr Mr yeah okay we're
talking about so we're talking about
that um we're talking about adding these
things to this list that the secretary
of state has created right because 154
has certain
requirements that the pre-election
certificate must have um and I think
think that the the opposition to it is
it's hard to determine the number of
absentee ballots not you um not returned
by the voters When you're counting
something that could still be coming in
right I think that's the point of
contention is there's going to you're
going to
create you're going to create this
number that's going to be inherently
disconnected because certain absentee
ballots do come in on Election Day um
and
that that's going to create theories
right we need recognize that that's
going to create
theories I don't like that right cuz
they're going to say look they had 30
absentee bouts showed up on Election Day
in w n in Manchester and be like yep cuz
that's how many normally get there on
Election Day in w n in Manchester um and
so like that's very
concerning
um like that's pretty much my only
objection to it is it's
like that you're using a post number in
a pre re elction
certificate and that's going to create
theories yes rep representative Grill we
don't hear from representative Grill yes
um if the inventory count with the
numbers that we're looking to add in is
already available on Election net and
there's already a tracking system in
place and then the concern this is
trying to address is about sort of
making that available to the general
public would it not be possible to print
out a report from election net and maybe
include that with the existing
worksheets rather than add these extra
line items which I think we're getting a
little you know turned around trying to
make heads or tail of those would we not
be able to just print out sort of the
existing inventory um reporting that is
being tracked yes B we representative B
fast address to her I I do agree um uh I
just don't know if that's what's
happening currently so um or if it's
consistent
representative
Brennan Mr chair um I'm hearing a lot of
Confusion And I I'm wondering if this
bill creates more confusion than is
necessary for a problem that really
doesn't exist and I'm wondering if the
tracking and inventory of
ballots um is done so sufficiently
already ready with the processes we have
in place and the new processes created
by HB by chairman Barry's favorite bill
um that has been signed into
law and so I just I'm wondering if this
is absolutely necessary at this time and
if it's really just solve trying to
solve a problem that doesn't exist thank
you representative Hamlet I I wish you
could all have the new pre election
certificate it is a pre-election
certificate because it says this is to
certify that in accordance with RSA 658
the ballots prepared by the clerk
meaning the city or town clerk have been
examined and counted these are the blank
ballots have been examined and counted
and we find that the total number of
official ballots excluding absentee
ballots and ballots used to test
electronic ballot counting devices is so
they've completely eliminated the
confusion about the absentee ballots
they they don't want them in this
pre-election this is just to certify the
blank ballots that the clerk has
bill okay I guess we'll call the role on
the motion of O pass as
amended representative bom yes
representative k Brian yes
representative quy yes representative
Ankerberg representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood representative Osborne
representative cutab yes representative
Lane no representative Bixby no
representative uh oh I skip
representative W I'm so sorry no no okay
representative Bixby just for the sake
of continuity no thank you uh
representative Hamlet no representative
Mirad no representative Bay no
representative Brennan no representative
Grill no representative Howard no uh
Representative rter no chairman Barry
chair votes yes that is um 11 no it's 11
to9 um with that the motion of V passes
Amendment fails on a vote 11 to9 is
there another motion yes representative
Lane I move I move that this bill is
inex expedient to legislate is there a
second Bon
seconds is there a discussion on the
motion to expedent to legislate
representative Mirad you think that
something an iron that version of this
could probably um generate consensus in
this committee might be next next
session but seems like there's some open
questions about exactly how to
operationalize it maybe we could
non-gain Amendment a Senate bill that
would be nice to nice to reverse course
on them for
once don't threaten me with a good time
don't threaten me with representative
Burnham I believe that the the a a quick
fix to this issue because yes there are
absentee ballots that do arrive on
Election Day is that that number can be
on the moderator's worksheet because the
moderator is there to have them counted
and it's in track with that I do agree
with that so that is a possible
Amendment to the moderator's worksheet
we'll have to find a nice Senate Bill
yes representative Hamlet it is on the
moderator's worksheet already we include
the absentee ballot on Election that
came in on Election Day yes so there you
go all right um with that the uh clerk
will call the role on the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate representative
Bo no representative Pome O'Brien no
representative qua oh representative
anchor
representative Burnham no Representative
warry no representative wood no
representative Osborne no Representative
kab no representative Wayne yes
representative Ward yes representative
Bixby yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes gr
yes representative Howard yes
representative
rapor yes chairman Barry chair votes no
um with that house spill 1523 we
reported out without
recommendation in the wildest vote of
all time um was that a 101 that was a 10
that was that yeah that's that's what we
familiar with that was 1010 um you can't
be doing these weird numbers in election
law man it's it's 11 it's it's 1010 or
200 it's all I know
um yeah yeah your parents were uh that's
right that's right um consp we conspired
to really mess with my math um with that
uh representative Lane you'll handle the
itl report and representative Burnham
you will be responsible for the
OTP a report um I
don't I can
you y so um John uh representative H
we'll do the report it's fine I'm not
I'm not overly concerned about it
um okay so now we're going to recess the
exe so here let me kind of give the
committee the disposition where we're
going to do going forward um so we're
going to go back into work session until
noon we'll break at noon we'll come back
at 1 um for uh the public hearings um if
we get a consensus at this meeting at
12:30 on the AI bill bills I'll call the
AI Bill vote um but you're going to have
to take me on my word that's the only
vote that I'm going to call so there's
not going to be any Tom Foolery on other
motions um if I call it at all so um
just do with what do with your time what
you will that is my intention
um and it's up to it's up it's up to you
um that we're back on the work session
1091 and um
we were talking about how much I loved
the online system
yeah and I'm gonna make the change and
you're going to make the change do we
want to do want to keep pounding away at
this or yeah I mean I'm almost done I
think yeah I think
so uh everybody that we we are in work
session so please keep the side chatter
to a minimum I will I will gavel this
thing down yeah and if anybody um wants
a copy of the red line thing I can go
upstairs and have get another copy made
you can take it home with you so I
apologize um we didn't get the committee
will come to order all right
representative Lane is being is speaking
so if you I want a copy of the red line
let me know I'll get one from upstairs
and give it to you um before you take
off so um the reporting how we're going
to report and we were kind of alluding
to all this is on page nine line 15 I
just want everybody to kind of be able
to look at
it um
or just highlight it so you can look at
it and and get back to me um with any
questions you might have So This Is How
They and this is where the schedule set
out this is kind of one of the the
critical ones that we changed so I mean
I'm not going to say much more on it if
if you want to read it and give me
comments or if you want to ask me
questions about it now but it's kind of
sections
that would be it I'm just awkward
silence okay and well I didn't want to
rush
anybody I get accused of on the internet
so people are so mean on Twitter but
you're reading it on the internet I know
that's what I thought was hilarious like
but I'm reading this insult that you're
hurling at me you're reading this
insult I know right yeah there's no
actual corrective this this it's I
noticed you don't use them much the
first thing you do when you look at your
computer is take them off thing ah okay
all right well again can take questions
and we can and I'll certainly take
questions anytime you know give me a
call email me whatever you want to do
okay and then um the last one I just
wanted to bring to everybody's attention
because we we it it really hasn't
changed much we just rearranged it well
this is second to last one are the
definitions of expenditure and
independent expenditure and they're on
that sheet that I gave you and they
reflect some of the comments but
essentially we shortened um the
definition of independent expenditure uh
a lot uh and and that's because we
defined expenditure we expanded out what
an expenditure was and then we just said
basically um an independent expenditure
is an expenditure that you don't do that
you can't do in concert or in
coordination with a campaign which is
essentially what the definition was we
just parsed it down a little bit more so
um if you want to look at the existing
language but the intent was not to
really change anything there it was just
to make it a little more
clear yes sir this I'm sorry yes
representative Howard so uh I think this
would be an appropriate time to bring up
the amendment that I had uh for hb1
1239 uh because it does address this
section uh so in line in the first line
of uh so 17 and
18 uh there could be uh we we could
insert something that states uh any
candidate whose expenditures did not
exceed
$1,000 uh during a reporting period
shall attest there too by placing a
check mark in a check box indicating on
the reporting form and on the same
timelines as set out in this
section uh the Secretary of State shall
include a a checkbox uh for this purpose
on the forms provided to candidates such
checkbox uh shall be in
substantially uh following form of
basically stating that they did not
spend uh under $1,000 and I can provide
uh that in written uh form for uh the uh
Amendment for 1091 if so are you are you
like you looking on page 10 and
includeed as a subdivision somewhere in
there is that what you're saying no no
uh I'm I'm
suggesting uh I mean we could
potentially put it on page 10 I
haven't because there's not much room on
page 10 but the the point there's a lot
of room on
page well yeah a lot of that is existing
a lot of that's yeah that's kind of what
I was referring to but the the point
being is that this way we would require
all candidates to uh signify that they
hadn't spent over $1,000 uh in a
reporting period uh and if they
uh and if they uh haven't then they can
easily just say it's not uh that I'm not
submitting any reports it's just that
I'm not spending over ,000 dollar so
then uh if we have people who aren't
submitting reports then we can have the
uh attorney general or Secretary of
State reach out to them and kind of see
what the situation is okay yeah and and
I I agree it goes into this section I
think it's a good fit as long as we're
all comfortable with that I I think
you're going to have to do some sort of
phase in on that we might guess yes repr
K thank you Mr chairman so I guess I'm
wondering are you suggesting that
somebody would have to submit that form
all nine times or would it are you just
saying it would be one time at the end
of
the cycle because to submit a form nine
times just saying that you haven't done
something it just seems quite repetitive
especially when you consider that state
reps that have run many times before
aren't really spending much on
campaigning anymore because people kind
of know them and so I think it's just
submitting unnecessary forms if they're
really not Su you know spending any
money but if it if it's just one time
perhaps that could be something that
could be a compromise but to submit it
nine times it just and then to hold you
know
somebody have me in trouble because they
forgot to I guess yeah uh to to respond
I mean I I think that if we did have it
required for only one submission it
would just give the Secretary of State
the opportunity to reach out to people
who haven't submitted these uh financial
statements uh to remind them hey by the
way if you haven't submitted these
statements you need to uh or check this
box
before uh there's any uh potential
investigation opened up beforehand if uh
somebody is not necessarily following uh
the proper financial guidelines so it it
is in fact just one time not all nine
times we we could we could work
something like that out yeah I believe
representative Howard is saying is he's
open to an idea of finding a middle
ground of people acknowledging that they
need to file reports
um even though they may not have to me
may not meet the threshold basically is
it my understand is like you want to
make sure that they know that if they
hit the threshold they need to file and
you want something from them that says
hey I know this I'm not going to do this
because I'm not going to spend this
money but I know that I I know that if I
was to spend this money I would be
filing this stuff is that is that fair
statement yes yeah that that would be
correct yes representative BM yeah I
mean on
that we all get a form or something from
the Secretary of State when we file for
office that you have to do this BL BL BL
BL so we know that but if I don't and
for many elections I've never filed and
I don't don't really want to because I
don't make it and so I don't think
forcing somebody to file they know what
the law says so why should they even
have to fill out a form saying that's
just extra paperwork for me the
Secretary of State and and forever so I
think the Counterpoint is you don't know
that they know what the law says because
you get a packet in the mail you throw
it away this is this is more of an
affirm the difference between this is it
becomes it goes from being a passive
notification to an active affirmation of
of saying you understand it
representative
qu yes I I I don't agree with the
amendment because I think we have a
presumption in this country that if
you're there's no evidence that you're
breaking the law you're not pursued and
you don't have to routinely make an
affirmation that you're following the
law I think that's important and it
imposes an extra burden on candidates in
terms of paperwork uh the way the
amendment is written I believe it
requires such
a uh report at every reporting period so
that is a significant burden especially
for people who are not incurring high
expenses but for me it's the the
presumption that we have not broken the
law unless evidence is presented we're
not
pursued so that's my view on I I I don't
I don't support your mment for that
reason tell we're going to put a pin in
that one and come back to it because I
think there's more to explore and we are
coming up on the noon and I have a
meeting at 12:30 so I want to grab lunch
um uh you guys know how I feel about
lunch um the only other thing that I
wanted to toss out there and we won't
talk about it right now is I want to
talk
about represent Lane in this
amendment talk about making the
disclaimers all the same um and I would
really love to get rid of the
address um the printed address on the
political advertisement the paid
political advertisement leave
the committee or the candidates name on
it the person paying the entity paying
for it leave that on there and they have
to be registered with the secretary of
state and all that information is
available on the Secretary of State's
website but it really just is like silly
that you have to print the address on
something um when you know if you're
trying to say it could be out of state
they could get a PO Box in state like
right no way but if yeah so if it's
available I think one one thing we did
was it was available on the Secretary of
State's website and another that if they
put a website the website had to have
the whole their website had to have it
is that similar or it's similar so so
the current law for political signage is
you have to have the paid for by right
paid for by committee name and then
underneath it you have to have either
the
uh chairman or a chairman or treasurer's
name and full address or you can
supplant all of that with just the
website so long as the website has that
information um so I I would like to see
that I really want to get those
addresses dropped off just because they
are
like it's just kind of wild like to put
especially on digital a if you read it
literally you're supposed to have it on
digital advertisement and if you try to
put that on a 50 by 300 Banner it takes
advertisement so I don't know I don't
know how people feel about that I mean I
I guess I kind of like to know where
they're coming from I'm a little nervous
that they they won't be filing with the
Secretary of State I mean they're GNA
have to spend what a$ thousand dollars
my uh to file my counter pun my
Counterpoint to that would be if they're
not fine with the Secretary of State
what makes you think they're going to
follow the disclaimer to begin
with
that's why we have the uh enforcement
Provisions at the end of the bill there
you go all right we're going to break
for lunch M Mr chairman yes I would two
things and I will be brief and I mean
it representative Lane and I have
discussed uh where there's an exception
for registration of a political
committee which exempts a political
Committee of a political party and I I
believe we're agree that that exemption
is appropriate so you we still agree on
uh my my view as full disclosure
chairman of a regional thre toown Pol uh
political Committee of a political party
is that it it does tend to reduce the
administrative overhead for operations
which are on a very small scale quite
often of course if expenses or receipts
exceed a $1,000 for such a committee
they still have to register and report
it so that was one thing uh and the
second thing is and going through this
in detail over the weekend I have noted
a number of uh things that you and I
could probably discuss that are more or
less typos so I want to suggest that we
do that and I think that was brief thank
you I just want to say you don't have to
say that you're the chairman of a three
toal committee you can just say that
you're a big wig party boss and we'll
all be fine with that only I'll see you
guys at 1 o' see you
guys boss qua over hereos
go
Mafia yeah that was one of our more
figures
e
back for those keeping track at home we
session we are now entering
a public hearing we'll open up the
public hearing on cacr 22 Rel leading to
the New Hampshire presidential primary
providing that the New Hampshire
presidential primary shall be the first
presidential primary of a presidential
election cycle uh looks like Senator
abbis will be introducing the bill
Senator abbis welcome to the house
election law committee welcome back to
the house Senator
abis thank you for the warm warm welcome
much appreciated I'm Senator Daryl abis
I represent District 22 serving the
community communities of pelum Salem Aon
and uh good afternoon Mr chairman and I
just want to thank everyone for hearing
me out today I'm asking you all you all
to support cacr 22 which ratifies our
first in the nation presidential primary
into our state
constitution if you talk to any anyone
out of state you know what really puts
New Hampshire on the map what what
people think of when they think of New
Hampshire I always hear that Live Free
or Die motto is a big one the old man in
the mountain in our first nation primary
well we all know we already lost the old
man unfortunately and so we lost one
tradition and this first in the nation
primary has been a tradition in the
state for 100 years over that and we've
done our elections the right way we have
extremely high turnout and this is a now
a thing because here in New Hampshire we
made it a thing it was not something no
one wanted to go first a 100 years ago
but because we made it a tradition and
what is brings to the state and really
gives us um puts us on the map now you
you see out out of state political
organizations want to take it away you
had you had a few terms ago uh back in
you know
2016 in 2012 it was the Republican
National Committee that was trying to
bump bump us from our primary now you
have this time you have the Democratic
National Committee doing it and then
that seems to volley back and forth
depending on what's going on in in the
political climate but timately we've
always stood strong but what's changed
is the is the amount of pressure these
aate political organizations are trying
to put on the elected officials to get
them to change our tradition to
accomplish their their motives and their
agenda not a New Hampshire agenda that's
an anti- New Hampshire position to take
is to give up our primary by putting it
into Constitution where I believe where
it should it should go uh they can put
all the pressure they want but the
right's not going to be given to the
people and I hear some people say should
this go in the Constitution or not if
you go through the New Hampshire
Constitution there are plenty of
election Provisions in the Constitution
whether it's qualifications for office
length of terms when the elections are
when the terms begin absentee ballots
disqualifications you name it there's a
lot in there uh involving um
qualifications of to vote filling
vacancies these are all in the
Constitution so so there's no reason why
this couldn't go into the
Constitution I think it's important to
look at the economic benefits our state
gets especially when you don't have an
incumbent or a former president running
for
re-election uh seeking because what
happens is you have basically you 10 15
20 candidates on each side we're talking
about office space they rent a venues uh
obviously they have staff it's hotels a
lot of rooms and meals Revenue comes
from that they
approximately when you have a um a
non-incumbents running on both sides
you're looking at around two billion
dollars in economic activity for the
state and that's a huge boost in our
Revenue so I think that's something to
keep in mind as well when I say this is
an anti-new Hampshire position that's
why I take that as beyond our tradition
we've made it a thing there's diners and
there's certain pit stops that have
become a tradition to stop at so I look
into why the narrative to take it to
take our primary way and maybe that's
just political rhetoric and
grandstanding but it really criticizes
the New Hampshire voters in our
demographics that's just not fair to the
New Hampshire voters it's not fair to
the elected officials in this state it
they claim that we lack diversity and
therefore are not worthy of the primary
any further and I think that's insulting
to the New Hampshire voters because
minority candidates in this state have
performed exceptionally well go on both
both sides Barack Obama won the state
twice in in 2008 and
2012 uh you saw in the second
congressional district Steve Negron won
the Primary twice he's American but he's
his ancestry is both Puerto Rican and
and Mexican
descent I'm of Middle Eastern descent
and I won my race for state senate by 25
points so where we lack in diversity
certainly minority candidates do have
the ability to perform well I think we
have you combine that with our turnout
um minority candidates um have a good
chance of getting elected this is what I
can tell so I think it's wrong to
perhaps attack our tradition we're based
on the demographics especially because
we really can't control who lives here
and who doesn't based on that so I think
that's inherently wrong uh I think what
what's happening now is by putting this
in the Constitution none of us would
ever have to worry about the out ofate
pressure again so I hope you would all
support this I know there's been
different polls on whether this the
people would support this I think if you
look at the undecided the this if you
exclude that number the over this would
pass overwhelmingly on the ballot um
it's supported by both parties so I
don't think this is a really a partis an
issue this is an out of New Hampshire
out of state New Hampshire issue or
instate issue and I think if you want to
support New Hampshire you would support
putting this into the Constitution if
you want to give into the OT of State
pressure or the DC
politics I guess that's that's the
decision to be made here I know where I
would stand so I'll answer any questions
are questions from the committee
representative Hamlet thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so what
would happen if another state decided to
put put it in their constitution that
they wanted to be first in the nation or
wanted to be you know one week before
any other election how how would that
work would we sue
them well I don't think we would sue
them they can do that now with the
current law if they so wanted to so
that's a that's a problem either way I
just know that the only way to protect
our first nation primary more than
having it in RSA is by putting it into
the Constitution because then to CH
change that you would have to basically
go through this whole cacr process can
put on the ballot because what's
happening now
is when they when the pressure that was
put on this go around it wasn't just to
change our primary date they wanted to
change a lot of our election laws as
well which in INF fairness to to any
political party it's kind of hard to
hold hold a political party to that
standard if they to pass and change all
these laws in order to maintain their
first nation primary it that doesn't
seem like that really makes sense they
if they wanted to deliver on that I'm
not saying they would I'm not sure they
could have so again to penalize the
Democratic party for that seemed very
disingenuous to me and I think as New
Hampshire voters and we should always
stand up for all voters As Americans we
want we don't want to be disenfranchised
like that so I think sticking together
dohe you thank you Senator do do you
think that this an amendment like this
might also serve a kind of a civic
education
function um I was surprised this past
winter at at how um few reporters
understood that elections are
administered by States not by national
parties in fact I was kind of surprised
that the national parties didn't
understand that elections are
administered by States and are regulated
by state laws and so maybe putting this
in a very visible place like the
Constitution which I ordinarily wouldn't
want to muck with anymore than
absolutely necessary might serve a civic
education function it most certainly
would and I'm I'm still not clear that
the some of the the national parties
understand that either either they think
that they can control how the the
elections are performed every state has
their own process and own election laws
and what what qualifications it takes to
be a state representative State Senate
it's different the terms are different
so I think for us it's also promoting
our tradition in in preserving it and I
think that's something that a lot of
people you you some people take it for
granted I think it's just something
that's always been there it's been there
my entire lifetime all of our lifetime
it's kind of always been but when I say
the it's this push to take it away is
getting stronger and stronger and
stronger so I think Now's the Time to
let's let's put a stamp on that
representative Howard
Mr chair and thank you senator for
taking my question uh so for our
University students whether that be
Dartmouth people currently attending uh
our University system uh or attending
say St ansam uh and their Institute of
politics do you think that this would
help protect those institutions in their
ability to recruit students over this uh
kind of uh monumentous event that we
take place every four years that draws
people in so that they can experience
this presidential
cycle absolutely and you see I mentioned
that we have much higher voter turnout
than other states and I think that a lot
of it is to attribute to the Civic
involvement and a big part of that is
the presidential primary I
mean just myself I get to meet numerous
candidates um throughout the the primary
process and that's a once in a-lifetime
opportunity for a lot of people for you
to be you know at a diner and see you
know Senator Scott or Governor Dan
santis I mean you would just see these
people
running you would just happen to run
into them sometimes when you're out in
the boat that's amazing and what's
really impressive and if you go back to
2020 in the primary you had candidates
perform really well in the state that
didn't have a war chest I think mayor
Pete Budaj did an excellent job he I
think he came in second but he left tied
with the most delegates with Senator
sand
and not if you if you put South Carolina
California any of those States ahead
you're going to need a war chest in
those much bigger States I think someone
like himself he really made a name of
himself in the state and was able to do
that where not every candidate can do
that but he did at the Grassroots level
and I think that Civic involvement
whether you're a Republican or Democrat
altogether questions from the
committee yes representative PR O'Brien
thank you uh my question is how does the
New Hampshire Primary in your opinion
benefit the entire country uh I I think
it does do you agree with that I think
it it benefits the entire country
tremendously I it does and as I was
saying before many years ago no one
wanted to go first it was the opposite
we were first everyone was happy because
it good you don't want to go first
there's a lot of pressure because
everyone's watching and you saw what
happened in Iowa in 2020 didn't go well
they're still getting criticized for it
we we have not had that problem here
we've always done a good job so I think
we set the tone I also think that you
have again without that war chest it's a
way to G gain momentum going going
forward as you head towards super
Tuesday and you saw um
Senator kobasa have a really good
performance in her debate you she was
projected to finish much lower and she
jumped right up the ladder and that was
kind of one of the talking points
leaving the 2020 primary so I think if
you look at how that benefits
us amazing plus the economic benefit I
always will go back to that just from a
pure Revenue perspective we shouldn't
give this up and again it's protected
now
questions from the committee there's
like a delay on the microphones today
saying none thank you Senator abbis um
are there any other people wishing to
speak to this bill I don't have any
other pink cards in my possession
representative ainur can you grab that
uh blue sheet for me and I will get the
I'm not wasn't ready for that one so
blank oh three
Nam okay
um there were two people signed in in
support that did not speak online there
were give me a quick
second we can't go anywhere till 125
anyway
so all right cacr 22 had nine in support
one oppose zero neutral with that I will
close the public hearing on cacr
22 and the committee will stand in
e
wow okay
we're back okay uh going to open up the
public hearing on Senate Bill 344
relative to Declarations of cany for
president United
States and representative excuse me
Senator gray I apologize it's I'm stuck
in I'm stuck in my ways Senator gray
welcome to the house election law
committee my name is James Gray I
represent Senate District 6 which starts
up in Alton gilmington comes down Route
11 to Rochester uh and I want you to
know Mr the chair that uh right over
there where representative akerberg is
sitting that's where the first seat that
I had uh in the house committee when I
was uh first serving uh 10 years ago uh
this bill is going to get you back on
break real quick uh it was a request of
the Secretary of State if you look at
the bill uh line uh 14 and 15 uh the
current uh form would have the secretary
State uh enter the date of the primary
when people are signing up for the
primary and as we have seen with more
and more challenges to the first in the
nation status uh he would like to re uh
put that instead of having to put in the
date in that form a date so designated
by the secretary of state which is what
the rest of the law says uh in different
places so that the form would just be
modified so that uh
uh he did not have to put a date in
there uh which then he would resend
later by having to move the primary and
if there's any questions I'd be happy to
answer them but this should get you back
on break real quick all right questions
from the committee for Senator
you
e
I guess I'll do this on the microphone
so I'm talking the rule was before this
year the chair could call the vote
immediately after a bill when we entered
the uh 201199 world we changed the rule
to where the chair can call the vote
with the consent of the of the ranking
member so I'm asking the ranking member
if she's for the point of expediency we
had no questions it's a housekeeping
bill can we just take the vote now and
that way I can write the report and we
can dispense with the
Bill
answer yes it's we got 14 okay all right
so with that we're going to end the
period of executive session on Senate
Bill 344 I will move the bill as ought
to pass is there a second I'll second
representative Lane second is there any
discussion on the
bill about as much about as many
questions as there were all right with
that the clerk will call the role on the
344 she wasn't ready for this one I
don't even have a form I'm just rating
it it's okay I I I have a feeling it's G
to be 14 to zero it's okay just yeah
there you go we'll do that one there you
go no no bom it's
okay uh yes representative
qu
representative representative Burnham
yes representative yes representative
representative
Mirad yeses Howard yes representative
Raptor yes chair chairman Barry chair
votes yes with that Senate Bill 344 will
be reported out as ought to pass on a
vote of 14 to Z is there any objection
to the bill being placed on consent
calendar
hearing none C the bill will be placed
on consent calendar I will close the
executive session on House Bill on
Senate Bill 344 um and see this is what
representative Mir head likes like we
just we just um we just chug along
that's that's you don't have to come
back or anything
just hear it vote and move on hear it
vote not a single question was asked not
a single statement was made I'll take
care of the committee report which I
will literally go in right right now so
we'll see you guys back at uh
read
e
for
okay we're back it's 1:50 going to open
up the exe uh the public hearing on
um Senate Bill 380 relative to moving
the state primary dates Senator Lang is
recognized Senator Lang welcome to
election law thank you for having me Mr
chairman again if you
go pass it I'm okay with that I don't
need you to have the hearing but um so
thank you um Senator Tim Lang um as many
of you know I I sered three terms in the
house including one on Election law and
uh now am I as a freshman Senator uh in
in the Senate and I'm an associate
member of the uh karaoke caucus as it
goes uh other that just means I'll go
but I won't sing so which is a benefit
to everybody anyway so um I'm here to
introduce the moving the state primary
bill um that bill it's a real simple
Bill we push everything back 90 days um
so all the filing dates get pushed back
90 days the vote will be the second
Tuesday in June um the primary reason
why you have this bill in front of you
as many of you know it's it's a struggle
sometimes to get in front of the voter
in that
really small window we have between
September and November um in some days
it's less than 60 days you ask for a
recount after the recount period and
everything else so the idea being is you
have such a small window of time to get
elected um to get out to the general
voter um we're all all politicians so we
all know that when you're talking in the
primary you're talking to your side of
the aisle and your and that's a
different discussion Point than when
you're talking to um the entire
electorate all together um the topics
you might cover are going to be
different so what this bill seeks to do
is give the general election voter the
most amount of time to vet the
candidates and to view the candidates
and get to meet the candidates so we'll
have um a March filing period with a
June primary and that gives you from
June until November to get out into your
community to meet all of your citizens
not just the citizens that happen to
have the same letter after their name as
you do but gets you to get to every
everybody um and and be able to have
them ask you questions and get things it
gives the voter the greatest opportunity
to to realize who they're going to vote
for in November as simple as
that are there questions for Senator
Timothy Lang yes representative Lane
welcome back Senator thank you
um not to make it all about me but we're
politicians I understand but this means
said I will be running during budget
session during and we have no staff the
house people have no staff nobody you
know so it makes it a little difficult
to run a campaign and do the work of the
house which um I'm just wondering if
this doesn't even make it harder for
people to do this job and discourage
people from doing this job because it's
a burnout it's a high burnout thank you
for the question so again remember it's
not a budget cycle right right we're in
the second year budget's over right so
it's not a budget cycle year that you'll
be running in um generally second year
bills are generally policy bills or or
procedural bills um so I I'll be
undergoing the same problem you will um
and and be honest with the Senate's
worse and when it comes to the second
half of the year because we have the
hundreds of bills you guys send us where
you might have the 50 or 75 that we send
you um and so it actually makes it worse
for the Senate to run but the way I look
at is this way is generally um you're
running for office all the time right
the reality is that you're you're you're
in front of your voters on a regular
basis uh I know that I take way more
constituent requests now and speak to
constituents now um in this cycle so
it's a it's not a budgetary year which
would have been a problem if it was and
I agree with you but it's not um it
tends to be a policy year or a
procedural year um not a budgetary year
so I think that makes it easier um and
was about the best I can say for you so
I do realize we'll be working and it is
going to increase our work effort
um nature of the job it's what we sign
up for if I may a representative Lane if
it's all about you may ask you a
okay can you describe to me when the
last time you had a primary
was I haven't had a primary but I'm the
exception I live in a very safe blue W
so wouldn't that make you more likely to
be
primary no I have General but but I I
understand I guess my concern is
actually recruiting people to do to do
this I mean it is hard enough to recruit
folks to do it and if you're going to
tell them in in your second year not
only are you going to be because this
March has been crazy I mean we have had
a lot of bills and
so and then you're also going to be
running a camp pain I I worry more for
people who are going to try and and and
run in the first time and and try to
recruit people and are you going to burn
people out maybe that's good and they
won't stay around as many terms I don't
know it it's just it's just a
consideration I'm not sure that I'll
vote against it for that reason it's
just it's a consideration so so I think
to the Chairman's Point most times
incumbents don't have a primary right
it's the other party that's has a
primary because they get more people to
jump in um and so um I I to a certain
extent I agree with the chairman that I
think that you're less likely if you're
in office to get a primary and which
means that you're not really running a
primary race you're just waiting for the
general to happen um if you're in office
um the people who are not in power in
that specific District or seat um is
more likely they have a primary more
people jumping in so and they're not in
the legislature so they have plenty of
campaign yes I'm sorry when we tried to
do this before uh the Secretary of State
date was not in favor of a June date is
that has that hurdle been uh resolved so
I ran this bill by him I I think he's a
he's reluctantly okay it's probably the
best way I could say it um is that it
meets all the requirements and all the
deadlines that he'll have it'll actually
make it easier for us to get things out
like absentee ballots and and um uocava
requests right so this will make it
actually easier for us to get those out
in a more timely fashion for the general
November election
yes if I recall the secretary's position
was to move it back one week yeah which
we all had a good laugh at
um further questions representative
Burnham Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question so in
regards to the previous bill that was
very similar to this
um um one of the concerns was and
especially during a presidential year is
um you know where our vacation State and
that would allow for a lot more
publicity and signs and things like that
which could be a little nuisance maybe
to our visitors um how do you feel about
that like that was something that was a
concern and is it a good thing or a bad
thing so I guess if you consider it this
way if you're doing a primary you're
gonna have a heck of a lot more signs
out um during the primary season um
because you have generally so even when
I ran from my Senate race I had three
three Republicans run against me it was
three of us total in the race um so that
means there's three signs out during the
primary season so by moving it to June
two-thirds of those signs would
disappear and it would only only be you
know the winner signs out from June
until a until November um rather than
multiple multiple parties so that's
number one number two um so the this
bill also came out of conversation with
the governor the Governor's in favor of
this bill he recently came out in favor
of this bill and again the reason being
is that a July and August date um we
have vacations to deal with and so that
anything that's in July and August you
run against people who are on vacation
and less like less likely to be in the
community to be able to vote um if we
just move it back until August um and so
he was in firm um support of a June date
because kids are still in school parents
are still here they can be engag and
then they don't have to deal with it
again until November when they when they
vote
again
representative
Grill yeah twice in one day this is a
rare treat was representative Grill
rarely rarely joins us in theay chairman
of the of the karaoke caucus just so let
you know got to got to make time for
Madam
chairman Koke recogniz well I I hate to
put another karaoke caucus members bill
under some scrutiny I think you guys all
know how I feel about a June primary so
I'm not TR yeah yeah best idea ever love
it so much um um so I think one thing
that um we love about politics in New
Hampshire is that for the lower ticket
races you know State Rep State Senate
it's more sort of Scrappy down to earth
Grassroots and we don't really get those
um $100,000 plus campaigns that you'll
see in State Rep braces for other states
um by moving the primary up I'm
concerned that we lose some of that sort
of face-to-face appeal and it puts more
pressure on candidates as we see
increased spending at the upper ticket
levels I'm worried that might trickle
down to the bottom of the ticket and we
might see increased pressure to run more
of a professionalized campaign with you
know slick uh signs and and palm cards
instead of just going out knocking doors
checking that box to spend um under $
th000 or not check in the box whichever
you know uh whichever ends up being law
um so are are you concerned as well
about potentially sort of seeing kind of
that scope creep with down ballot races
and um the impact on kind of our sort of
unique political culture thank you for
the question so um having having run now
a five four five six campaign just for
state house whatever it was um I don't
I'm not concerned about that again I
mean I will say that when I came to the
Senate I had a really eye opener about
how much it costs to run for a senate
seat um we're already having $100,000
campaigns for for a majority of the
Senate seats um over in the Senate um I
know over the house there's been a few
already that have broached 100 Grand in
in a race um yeah specials yeah so um so
well I don't think this will change that
just moving the date I don't think
changes it so that it's it becomes a
professional race I think the dates the
dates the date right so the same thing
you would do from June to September
you'll just be doing from March March to
June so I don't think that changes it at
all again I think the best benefit of
this bill is you get more access to the
general voter the voter gets to find out
who's my candidates let me go find out
about them rather than I'm not sure who
my candidates are yet I go to wait till
I get through the primary then I can
figure out who they are and then I get
to go meet with them and I only have 60
days for that window of time so I think
that this just gives greater access to
the voter to the people whose name is
November other questions from the
committee all right thank you Senator
Timothy Lang we really appreciate you
being here your presence is always
chairman not calling me the former
member former representative really
appreciate you really always so good
seeing you thank you for being here um
uh hearing can I have the blue sheet
representative
anenberg all right now that he's gone we
time it's just DL yeah okay all right so
we have one person signed up who didn't
speak who was in support um online why
did I come off of that page I don't I
don't know why I did that to
H oh I see what a weird way of numbering
it
um
huh I'm looking here it's uh it's
strange how they've
380 there we go it's not in it's in
numerical order so it's not like 380
Senate Bill 380 could be after House
Bill 379 that's what was confusing me
because I thought it wasn't in
alphabetical order it was in numerical
order ignoring the first part of it uh
online there were three people in
support seven opposed zero neutral um no
written testimony okay with that we're
going to close it up and I'll see you
you
I
good
news
e
yeah all right I think we're back 215
right y
25 um going to open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill 490 FN relative
to verification of the checklist uh the
Senate has sent uh daily fette to
introduce the bill
afternoon chairman Barry and members of
the committee my name is Daley Fett and
I am the Senate majority caucus director
I'm here today to introduce Senate Bill
490 on behalf of Senator avard Senate
Bill 490 changes the verific
verification of the checklist from 10
years to five years this bill is a
request of Senator aar's constituents
that have been monitoring the ver voter
checklist in Hollis and by verifying the
checklist more often it will be more
accurate and will help mitigate the
possibility of voter fraud I'm keeping
it very brief we have some gentlemen
behind us who are uh going to be willing
to take any questions for you so I'll
will uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak today okay um next up will be
weie good afternoon Mr chair and
esteemed members of the election law
committee uh for the record my name is
Robert warry I'm a representative for
Hillsboro District District 13 the great
town of
Hudson um I have before you
a um sort of analysis or if you will a
written report um just to cover it
briefly um the five as proposed in Sp
490 as amended the voter verification is
between April 1 and August 1st and
fiveyear intervals um with a four-year
look back in the four years preceding
the year of the verification or
Purge I've di I had considered making a
mathematical model but uh chose to
present this diagram instead because I
thought that might be at least a little
clearer um you should have a
copy there Mr
this thank you all right so um and part
of part of the concern is that there's
some variability introduced by having it
on a fiveyear cycle since presidential
races are on a four-year cycle the
potential impact of accurate checklists
using a five-year verification interval
in order to really understand the impact
you have to map it out using a 20-year
perspective because it's you you're sort
of using the lowest common denominator
between fouryear intervals on the
presidential races and five-year
intervals as proposed in the bill um
it's seems reasonable to assume that an
increasing degree of checklist accuracy
drift or degradation occurs each year
following The Purge this is point two um
therefore if if you consider this with a
five-year cycle and a four-year look
back the accuracy of the checklist will
vary across the presidential races as
shown in diagram one now what's the
concern um because the presidential race
is often considered the more important
race a potential exists for variable
accuracy in the checklist and lower
accuracy in four out of the five
presidential races occurring in a over a
20-year period um because of this
variability or inconsistency in
checklist accuracy for presidential
elections I am uh opposed to sp sp
um I say just in the analysis it is
worth noting that for fall elections the
checklist is most accurate in the year
of purges perform and it drifts each
successive year until the next Purge is
performed so
um so I tried to think about this a
little bit more discreetly and uh I'm
moving to two page two now so what is
the verification objective obviously we
we would like there to be an accurate
checklist all the time um uh and I think
there's perhaps at least among the
voting population less less of a concern
for the accuracy of the checklist during
the midterm and local elections because
there's generally a lower voter turnout
during these
races um so at least by voter turnout
the concern does not appear to be as
great for those non-presidential
election Cycles so with that
consideration perhaps you know what is
what is the objective or verification
that we're concerned about it's really I
think to have the most accurate
checklist during the presidential races
such an objective was not overtly stated
or was at least not considered in the
2022 report on this from the special
committee on voter confidence however if
you look at the factors of voter
interest as identified by voter turnout
in presidential elections and based on
the demand for integrity in the voting
process as expressed in the 2022 report
for the special committee on voter
confidence this would seem to be the
leading and most reasonable objective
for accurate checklists and their
verification now why why don't we just
do this every year then um well I think
we have to have some considerations for
the supervisor of the checklist
workload so generally I think we and
we've discussed this before during
previous bills generally the increase in
the supervisor
workload um caused by more frequent
checklist verifications is offset by the
reduction in the number number of Voters
that would have to be removed or
processed because of this greater
frequency of
verification but I think there are still
two sort of concerns what is the concern
for workload during federal election
years um when there's more going on and
what is the concern for workload with a
more frequent verification interval I
think uh The crucial workload question
is at what point does the supervisor
workload concern outweigh the concern
for the accuracy of the checklists
that's I just tried to boil it down to
what's the kind of logical decision that
we're trying to make here so I think
there are a couple of different ways of
looking at this um if we're trying to
meet this objective that I've kind of
argued for that we want the most
accurate checklist during the
presidential races then I think we have
and we also want to take into account
the concern for supervisor workload then
we have potential
a few options here so op option one
would be a four-year interval in
presidential election years if the most
accurate checklist is desired in a year
of a presidential election and less so
for midterms and local elections then
the verification process should be
performed in the year of a presidential
election and it should be performed at a
minimum of a four-year
interval option two if performing that
verification during a presidential
election year is deemed to be too
burdensome for the supervisor of the
checklist then the verification should
be performed in the year just prior to
the presidential election this was a
bill that was uh previously introduced a
few weeks ago House Bill
1369 um a third option exists and I I
think we just have to address it because
obviously the most accurate checklist
would be obtained by performing the
verifications annually or at least every
other year um however I think some would
consider this to be too frequent of an
interval because of the demand on the
supervisors so if however if if
performing the verification more
frequently was not the issue and um but
performing the verification during a
federal election year whether it be the
presidential race or a midterm then the
verification could be performed every
other year during local election so I
think there are ostensively uh three or
four options that I think are better and
provide more accurate
checklists at the time when voters are
most concerned about the accuracy of a
checklist and that's sort of the end of
my analysis and I'm happy to take any
questions if there are
any other questions from the committee
representative
Lane that is not my strong point so um
I'm looking at the diagram yes so is is
the problem is that in the fourth year
is that because you're doing it in
a presidential year but you're not
capturing a presidential primary a
presidential election is that what
you're saying yeah so if in the in the
diagram uh the smaller box bolded on
your left hand in that sort of leftand
column would be the year of the purges
this is illustrating the
fiveyear as proposed in the bill if we
assume that there is some sort of
degradation of the accuracy of the
checklist in each successive year prior
to the next Purge then it gets the
checklists get worse as you move to the
right in the successive
years okay and that doesn't obviate the
supervisors of the checklist from doing
their normal job in removing people but
I think we saw in the
2021 Purge that that's not always well
practiced because we moved a quarter of
a million roughly voters from the
so when you
say um clean I guess I'm trying the word
Purge bothers me because what what
happens is is if somebody doesn't if
they haven't run you know voted in that
time they get kicked off and they don't
know that they're kicked off until they
show up is that
correct
well they well I mean the the process is
that they would have a letter sent to
them they would have you know a time
period to respond to that and if somehow
they you know life was busy and they
didn't actually respond to that letter
they could always re-register and of
course we um have the capability to
register same day as uh needed in this
state I think also if um if you listen
to the Senate hearing on this bill one
of the things that they said is that of
the approximately 100% that were
removed only five or 6% re-registered so
it's a very small incremental impact on
um people who are being removed in in
that so I again I I base that solely off
of what I heard from the Senate hearing
analysis sure why not so what would be
well that's a good question in my in my
orig Original House bill I had proposed
actually the year before a presidential
election I think I think actually the
most accurate would be during the year
of the presidential election I think
satisfy the that would I think that
would satisfy the voter
confidence objective that we're trying
to achieve I I am concerned about what
impact it would have on the supervisor
of check during a federal election year
because I think their activities are a
little more um I think they're busier
and um and and that was why I originally
kind of chose oh do it the year before a
presidential election in my house bill
but I think having kind of done this
analysis I think all and all things
considered I think I would prefer it in
um you I also think as we I also think
it's important that we make sure we
um recognize if there's going to be a
workload um impact to the supervisors of
the checklist I think for most Wards and
towns I don't I don't think it will be
huge but obviously there are some areas
where it will be and I think that's
that's what we kind of need to make
people aware of and so that they can
adequately prepare I think the the good
part of that is that you know um
hopefully we would have a um startup
date of of a reasonable time period to
give people enough advanced warning to
prepare for this in in larger towns
where this might have more of an impact
I mean Hudson is 10th largest population
Center in New Hampshire and therefore I
think it you know I'm concerned about it
from that perspective
so you're welcome further questions from
the committee representative
wood Mr chair uh you mentioned that uh
the amount of time before the
presidential elections important but you
kind of alluded and I'm just going to
for clarity that uh repeating it the
same time in a cycle would be also be an
advantage too for the way you perceive
it you mean in a like a four-year cycle
is that what you mean correct yeah I I
do think there is an advantage to that
because I think
again I'm I'm basing my definition of an
objective based on voter turnout and
because of that I think that's where the
most interest lies and that's where
voters would like to see that greatest
uh point of accuracy a followup yep so
if you picked a down year you can always
pick a down Year from what you said is
that correct well you a down year as
what the um the um checklist people
people have to do obviously a
non-election year versus a strong
election year right yeah you could pick
a a local year as opposed to one in
which we hold midterms or the
presidential races again I think it's
it's the key
is is is
controlling the amount of years where
the degradation occurs before that next
presidential
race last follow up sure
so regardless of the math there seems to
be a clear from what you're saying is a
clear advantage of a the of a four-year
cycle and no advantage of a fiveyear
cycle I I
think if if you look at the diagram I
think it kind of
outlines you know you're going to get
very and again there are some
assumptions there's an assumption that
the checklist accuracy degradates over
that s each successive year and that um
therefore you're going to get some
variability across a 20year cycle as
um these were a lot of the concern or
some of the concerns that I had when I
originally proposed the house bill um I
finally sort of figured out a what I
hope is a somewhat simple way of
sure is there a difference other than
the cycle time and amount of time is
there a a a big difference between this
bill and the house bill in your no in P
fundamentally no no I I think it's the
welcome representative M head is Rec
um could could you review what the um
criteria is for for um you know
receiving a 30-day n letter or or being
purged from the list so I think um yeah
the RSA talks about you know um
different scenarios transfers of you
know moving um citizen notification
death um other things where someone is
uh presumed to be no longer eligible for
voting because they basically are no
longer in that voting
municipality the supervisors of the
checklist upon hearing this
information um if they can't verify it
through other means uh through US post
office or uh Secretary of State's office
then they send out a registered letter
and uh I think it's a registered letter
certified letter something like that and
they uh then uh
have 30-day notification I believe
that's the basic process I'm probably
not describing it as accurately as the
RSA States it but that's basically
it um is this fouryear look back does it
look to see who hasn't voted in the past
four years and presume that those people
haven't voted are are yeah that that's
what that that sort of uh arrow pointing
to the left it's a look back on the
years preceding the per the sorry
verification someone doesn't like Purge
uh proceeding the verification so it
would so if the if the verification were
to occur in uh in this diagram if it
occurs in 2026 then it looks back uh to
January of 2022 so 25 24 23 and 22 and
then one last follow please yes um and
in the absence of something like Eric
which has you know database people have
moved and died and so forth uh we're
looking to see who's voted who hasn't
and I want to ask whether you're
concerned about the following kind of
scenario a very good friend of mine
um does not think that politics
generally serves her she she's a
workingclass person and uh and and she's
skeptical of of the whole class of those
to serve an office along right and the
one of the only candidates she's ever
been excited about that I've known is is
uh Donald J Trump and when he appeared
on the national ballot in 2016 she
decided she's going to vote M um she
does not vote generally um and voting
costs her money because she bills by the
hour she's
self-employed um I'm really concerned uh
that somebody like she will be purged
she will not you know respond to a
letter she actually has trouble just
paying the rent and moves to surp with
surprising frequency the letter probably
go to one of her previous addresses and
this sort of person who you know who who
Who's inspired to vote by by very rare
candidates who can really appeal to
Ordinary People in the way that
professional politicians don't will find
out on that day when they want to vote
for someone like Donald Trump that
they're not on the list are we concerned
that this is going to this is going to
harm people like citizens like
this well I think if they if they move a
lot they probably are going to have to
fill out an affidavit regardless um so I
I think we do have you know same day
voter registration so I I think um that
ability um alleviates that scenario and
if
she's uh if your friend
is has voted in the previous
presidential election for such a
candidate and and that candidate runs
again well then she would still be
eligible of course if she moved she'd
have to fill out the necessary paperwork
and stuff but but I think those people
are not disenfranchised by that
situation that you
described
ative Hamlet thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my
question um so I'm not so much concerned
with the the F five years or four years
I have to study the chart but my
question is down on
line8 this bill is requiring the
supervisors to meet at least once a
month now in the city of Portsmouth the
supervisors do meet once a month but my
understanding is that in the very small
town they do not need to and they and
they don't want to well
so Senator fortunately Senator gray is
here to answer such questions so you can
you can ask him directly okay so um that
portion was not mine so I will uh to I
will to to be fair representative Hamlet
representative where he signed in an
opposition to the bill so he may not be
the one to ask that question
to because I I I want the fouryear cycle
and under the scenario that I described
for the for the reasons I described so
just just as a point of clarity just you
so all right um yes that's any other
questions for representative Wy uh
alucino good afternoon Mr chairman and
members thank you so much for uh
inviting us and letting us speak um just
one quick question to representative or
Mr Morehead the concern you have about
your Donald J Trump voter that already
exists because it does happen at the
10-year cycle so as the previous
gentleman alluded to uh uh the the
safety net is is that you go to your new
Miss municipality or your current one
you present your ID you vote if you
don't have your ID you do have the uh
affidavit ability anyways I appreciate
the opportunity um we did a deep dive in
Hollis over the past three years our
findings really reveal a starting real
starting reality that one in five to one
in four names on our Town's voter roles
were just flat out illegitimate as you
know the state of New Hampshire's 10year
Purge successfully removed an incredible
250,000 names considering the state's
population of 1.3 million and factoring
in a significant portion of aged 17 and
under were essentially cleaning up an
incredibly high percentage of Voters
that were on our list Statewide because
some cities and towns do a fabulous job
this highlights that a substantial level
of inaccuracy has been uh across the
state's remaining towns exists we must
ask why and what can be done to help
mitigate and bring better accountability
across the board in Hollis alone in 2020
our US Census population was 8,342
people our supervisor the checklists
signed their names to declare that
approximately 7,700 names were eligible
and on our roles this was outrageously
high and our voter tally in November
2020 was
5,890 that produced roughly a 76% voted
turnout with the Hollis population of 17
and under we knew the voter roles were
wildly off and we and should have fallen
in the range of anywhere from 5700 to
6,300 not the 7700 that was declared and
signed off on in fact the imminent State
Purge called 1390 names to be removed
since that happened so close after the
10-year Purge and I'm sorry so close to
the
election um our new number of
631 people on our registration list
produced an incredible 93% voter turnout
upon further investigation we discovered
a public list of over 500 names of
people on our voter list who either
should have not been on the list at all
or at least been looked at as they had
gone to the post office independently
submitting permanent change of address
requests not vacation forward my mail
but permanent change of address requests
after presenting these findings to our
local checklist people a cleanup effort
um resulting in one in hundreds of names
came off our list so looking at those
numbers using the same numer Ator of
5,890 people voting and then coloring
these names now we were looking at 98%
possibility of voter turnout that's
pretty
incredible additionally over the last
few years we've had since that time
actually from 2019 through current we've
have over 200 new homes built in our
town that's the possibility of 200 to
400 new registrations of Voters in
December 2023 after all the culling and
the pushing and cleaning our voter roles
were down to
606 that's only 116 more people who than
who actually voted in
2020 now if we go look at the new
residents that came in town that are on
the December 2023 list that pushes our
our number to Just numbers that should
at least uh bring about some curiosity
to be more uh po forthcoming in
addressing accurate voter purges and
cleanups
um it just shows you how important
cleaning the voter roles are the
checklist people by and large all
well-meaning but a little State
intervention in terms of uh increasing
The Purge would really be a big help and
I think actually personally would smooth
out their year-to-year
duties um let's see here uh we found out
in in our particular town that one
checklist person stated specifically we
refrain from sending out 30-day letters
because we know the state will do the
work for them this is in the year or two
his words leading up to the state Purge
so what's happened in this particular
case is this particular checklist person
in the board was was assuming that the
state Purge which is a different
criteria than what they do was going to
do the work for them so the state
intervention of increasing The Purge
will actually help mop up a few things
where some things might be falling under
the
radar anyways um one one person from the
checklist said we knew we were not
sending out 30-day letters on a timely
basis we knew the voter roles were
overinflated um so as you can see we
have the variable aspect of human uh
activity affecting the efficacy of our
list approval of this measure some form
of it will help take the accuracy to a
new level in the state and ensure
confidence and integrity in the process
and help provide a nice check and
balance uh without this uh tension of
this issue controversy increases in
every election and I think the best
thing is is just to mop up as much as we
can keep things clean so thank you so
much will you be taking questions from
the committee sure are there questions
from the committee representative wood
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I missed I have a couple of
questions uh but I missed the
introduction where you're from I
apologize I didn't say it Al fulchino
Hollis New Hampshire no okay I did get
your name I apologize but the group that
put that did this are you a five
citizens five citizens there is no
Organization no so five citizens five
people just
literally you had people from both
parties in the last few elections saying
all the basic stuff he's not my
president this election stolen how do
you prove these things they can be
challenging so the the goal of this was
what are the basics we can look at it
was very obvious simply by looking at
the US Census and the number of people
on our roles didn't look right
unfortunately when we questioned it in
fact what we found was in our town there
had been no meeting minutes posted for
years now according to the RSA now we're
all green to this we just said hey your
math don't look right we went privately
we even offered volunteerism in our
community we found out from the
Secretary of State's office Senator rard
other people State reps sheriffs um when
I showed them casually here and there I
said we don't have mean we can't do the
math to figure out where we should be
the checklist people in our town
rejected outright any um attention to
this matter if you go to the Hollis
website today you will see the select
board has meetings going back like 10
years if you go to the checklist you'll
see the meetings started in 2022 why
because we said
hey nobody can do the math there's an
RSA that says you you should have
minutes we forced it actually we tried
three times Mr Bud Fitch and the
Secretary of State's office got involved
he contacted them and he said hey guys
make minutes okay the first minutes they
gave us all had redacted signatures all
of their signatures were redacted we
said forget that we're not here to crush
anybody we only looked at the numbers
that our checklist gave us they didn't
add up so either a list matters or it
doesn't either you have a reason to have
a list or you don't okay not here to
change the world none of us were we just
said uh something doesn't look right
we're here to assist and um that was
part of the Genesis of uh this whole
thing we kept finding things that didn't
make any
sense
well if I got your your understanding or
your math correctly you started out with
about 71% 7700 people the voter turnout
in 2020 was we were told was 76% 76 yes
and then you went from the first
correction so the first correction was
the state did their Purge now that
happen so close to the election you have
to uh recognize there's really only one
variable in that three or four month
period some people can move in and can
move out we had 1390 people come off we
did not sell uh you know that many
houses and that we we have we're a small
town so it stood out in our mind that uh
over 10 years why are we not keeping it
just a bit cleaner right okay and then
the third correction the third
correction you instigated your group
instigated so what happened was this we
wanted the system to work we uh we
actually were called by secretary
scanlan's office by the Secretary of
himself to come up and speak to him he
spoke to us for 2 hours he heard enough
that said we need to meet again he
brought in the Attorney General's office
he asked the SEC supervisor the
checklist from Halls to come up they
didn't show up okay we want to be team
players we're very green at this we kept
in our back pocket a list of 500 plus
names of people who had permanently uh
moved moved out of Hall they went to the
post office and said I don't live here
they signed their name I live in another
town in New Hampshire or where the
reason we held on to it was we wanted to
see the Secretary of State who ended up
coming down to the town hall as having a
sit down with them do the job here's
your training here's your phone numbers
here's your websites we didn't see names
coming
off so we then a gentleman by the name
of Mike McCormack and I went into a uh
last June or July to the checklist board
and we said here's a list of a bunch
more names it was over 500
their comment was this I guess we're
going to have to go to the uh select
board and get more postage and then the
big one for me was one of the checklists
person gave to me like the biggest
statement I could ever hear in this
matter you know Al in the year or two
leading up to the state Purge we refrain
from sending out 30-day letters because
we know the state will do the job for us
and at that point I said Tom I know the
guy we coached together years ago I said
the state has a slightly different
criteria than you you have your own
guidelines they have theirs they don't
do the job for you in the same vein that
you're alluding to so I said the problem
is is when you say you refrain that's an
active verb you are saying that one 16
to 13d of your term you're refraining
from doing your task another checklist
person said we knew we were not sending
out the 30-day letters on a timely basis
now the problem is this creates doubt in
anybody's mind who has any logic because
now you start to say okay well what's
the real
numbers okay and if you have to start
asking those questions how can you have
any belief in the
system so they took off a bunch more
606 are you aware of any other towns
with similar
problems well as I said to the Secretary
of State and I said alluded to here if
you have 250,000 names coming off the
list and some towns do a fabulous job
just look at the percent of the state
Purge 3% 5% we ended up being about 22%
off so the numbers speak for
themselves I can't tell you that there's
another town that says we refrain from
sending out 30-day letters I I only can
tell you our town that's what I
witnessed so I'm not here to criticize
any other town but the numbers
demonstrate that there's not enough
cleaning it would be wonderful we lived
in an older era where there wasn't so
many people moving around and um Trent
populations but we live in an era now
where hey we have the computers we can
do the math we can press the button
clean the list we can do the fouryear
look backs we can do it more frequently
to achieve a better list it just
benefits
everybody
okay thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question sure would you object
if it if uh right now it states five
years if it was four years based off the
testimony previous no I wouldn't object
at all I think any towards
frequency is wonderful I mean our
initial submission was two
years again um this is something
everybody has to coales around I think
just generally speaking if we do it more
frequently I think we're all winners I
really
do other
questions see hearing none thank you uh
next up will be Senator
gray and uh we're going to do a two for
here folks so what's going to happen is
I believe Senator G you are testifying
on 490 is that correct or am I incorrect
on that I'm going to testify both of
them if you want yes so what I would
like you to do represent uh Senator gray
is uh testify on 490 and then I'll
recess 490 and allow for the
introduction of 5:30 to respect your
time uh we will come back to 490 we've
done this before folks it's okay um but
we want to respect the Senator's
time okay so we're doing 5:30 first uh
we're doing 490 first you're testifying
on 490 and then I'm going to recess 490
and then you're going to introduce F uh
you're going to introduce 5:30 uh after
my name is James Gray I'm Senator
representing Senate District 6 which
starts up in Alton gilon goes down Route
11 to
Rochester uh the reason I filled out a
pink card it sound like you might want
to ask me a question or two I am the one
who made the final uh draft uh amendment
that put the bill into what it is and
took it from two years to uh five years
Etc uh that was done after uh talking
with the Secretary of State um I don't
care what your frequency is uh but
remember every time you do one of these
the 30-day letters there is an expense
to it um so you know when you add up all
that postage uh five years seem to be a
good compromise uh if you do go to four
years you may want to look at looking
back either either five or six years to
make sure you get two presidential
elections one would be the example given
that somebody missed a presidential
election and that's the only one they
vote in they'd have to miss two in a row
if you look back six years on a
four-year cycle um again that's up to
you um the um at least meeting once a
month on the
supervisors uh if there are changes out
there the are supposed to go to the
supervisor and you don't want a big
delay between the time you identify him
and so uh I believe that that came from
the Secretary of State but don't quote
me right now I I I just don't remember
when that one came whether it was in the
original bill or whether that was a
change I made and with that I will
answer any questions that you have
questions from the committee
representative Hamlet looks like she
want to ask a question you Mr chairman
thank you Senator
gray so my question is in line eight is
do you think it's necessary to require
the small towns to for the supervisors
to hold meetings every
month I think that uh if there is
pending things that they're supposed to
be reviewing uh certainly the secretary
of state is sending out uh death notices
from various uh newspaper and from the
the system uh they are also reviewing
the permanent change of address stuff
from the post office that all goes in
there uh I would find it you know even
well the very small ones I mean you're
not going to have a whole lot of
Supervisors that have to meet anyway but
but you know those are the reasons that
I would see that it would be needed uh
you may in there if uh uh you know the
supervisors will meet you know if it's
within so much of an election because
you do want new voters to be able to
come in and meet with you and and you
may want to put in there that they have
to meet once a month if uh uh there's
pending actions identified in the datab
base and stuff you know so again
I I would just assume leave it the way
it is I mean uh but you know that's up
to you guys but there there usually is
changes that that have to be made so
you from the committee
hearing none I'm going to thank you
Senator gray I'm going to recess the
public hearing on 490 we are coming back
to it um going to open up the public
hearing on Senate bill 530 relative to
reports of receipts and expenditures
filed by political Committees of
candidates and candidates and Senator
gray is recognized for the purpose of
introduction of the bill uh thank you my
name is uh James Gray I represent Senate
District Six which starts up in Alton
gilmon comes down rout 11 the
Rochester uh this is a rewrite of a bill
that uh your chair and I have discussed
several times uh this uh talks about
sizes of fonts and other things um the
discussion that we had way back when is
he wanted a 14p point font and I was
comfortable with an eight because it was
going to be in a PDF file or whatever
and all I had to do was you know Mouse
over it or spread my fingers depending
on whether I had a touchcreen or not uh
but it really does get down to that uh a
lot of people who file paper and fact
simil that into the secretary of state
that you cannot read the attachments
that there were the amount of
information they put in there that the
font that they use is so small uh that
it ends up being blobs on the piece of
paper uh when one of my Senate opponents
did that I went and
demanded of him to give me a a readable
copy of it and he kind of laughed and
says hey you know there's nothing that
says I couldn't do it so I did it you
know and uh that wasn't a real good
answer to me but you know that's the way
it was so uh this we did take out uh at
the request of the Secretary of State
the ability to send these things in on
facts uh so if they are sending them
in if they are sending them in um you
know in a PDF format or other acceptable
format to the Secretary of State uh it
will be expandable so that the amount of
the font becomes more moot than uh and
I'm willing to answer any questions you
have other questions from the
committee representative Lane it it's
it's somewhat related um because we just
finished working on a campaign finance
bill where we actually want to require
people to use the the campaign Finance
system and a lot of that stuff that you
put into yours is in another Senate bill
that's coming to you Okie doie so we
were hoping and then use the and phase
it in so that it so that it doesn't all
I believe that the basis of the bill
that I wrote uh was the a copy that both
you and Aaron right had worked on and I
was able to redraft that you know making
some of those changes that the Senate
always does as you know uh and uh that
should be coming over to you because I
believe it's uh already through the
Senate they're faster than we are we're
still drafting further I don't get paid
anymore though further questions from
the
committee um along those lines as you
know Senator we are working on um our
house bill is 1091 just so you know um
and we are going through the entire
section of
664 um trying to streamline it um make
it more understandable um any objections
to us working your concerns into here
into
um the only thing that uh that I would
object to um is that the secretary state
does want to get this one through uh
that the fax machine problem is
is the reason why most of the stuff that
comes in that it's put up on the online
is not readable and this not only takes
care of the fax machines but it also
gives them the right to uh to reject
stuff and say they you have to give me a
better copy uh so that would be the only
thing uh if it's in both you certainly
know that we can deal with it in the
wherever representative Lane thank you
for taking my question um so I noticed
that this only applies to a political
Committee of a candidate or a candidate
is there any reason you would not apply
this to all political
committees um if you look at your
draft I think we're going to get down to
candidates and political committees and
we're not going to have candidates
candidate committees you know so I think
we're getting down lower I'd have to go
back back and review that to exact you
know why I worded it the way I did uh
but you know it is we are attempting to
make it
consistent um like I say one of the
things that that your notes did was take
instead of candidate and candidate
committee there is candidate committee
okay and then when you get to the other
ones uh there is consolidation also
so
other questions from the Committee
hearing none thank you Senator I'm going
to recess the public hearing on Senate
bill 530 we're going to reopen the
public hearing on Senate Bill 490 um Mr
next up is Anthony Stan
nizzy yes you have no idea how many
names have been butchered from this
chair so I got it right I'm very happy
um this is the last pink card I have for
this one representative can you grab the
blue sheet for me do appreciate you
getting my name somewhat correct I've
heard it a lot of different
ways uh first of all uh thank you very
much I appreciate being here the
opportunity to speak with all the
representatives and representative Barry
uh I just want to interject something
that wasn't mentioned as everyone spoke
uh because there is concerns that we
don't
disenfranchise any voter that would like
to vote and able to vote and that sort
but uh no one ever mentioned the town
clerk the town clerk is an active member
in working with the the supervisors of
the checklist with
registering potential voters um change
of address information whatever they
they they they do act in a role there
and can provide uh checklist to the
general public that's an RSA as well so
there are opportunities for people that
want to vote to vote to contact the town
clerk if the if the secretaries of the
checklist on actively having a meeting
and also meetings can be conducted by
zoom and uh they can't I Okay the reason
I said that is because Board of
Selectmen often have members uh zoom
into the meetings and kind of that way
but I apologize for that statement um
anyway just to move ahead um I've had a
lot of experience in the healthcare
industry so I kind of think along those
lines when I think of things that aren't
quite right I've had both on the
provider side in healthc care and I
worked in Industry uh as well in a lot
of areas in analytics and so on just to
uh round that statement out um the
10-year Purge versus a two-year Purge uh
the major points I want to address is
inflation voter roles Statewide it's not
just a town issue when you look at the
250,000 names that are purged and then
you start looking at other information
uh and this was in 2020 there were uh
1,1
19,23 to registered voters uh with
75,6 611 registered same day voters when
you look at that and then you look at
the US population Center
for New Hampshire was
1399 million so it's almost 1.4 million
that if you look in at the underage
under 18 years of age resulted in 18% of
the population then you start looking at
it and saying what are the el el
eligible voters that was 1.48
million and in order to get to the
numbers of actual voters you'd have to
have
97% of the eligible population to vote
to get to those numbers when I always
look at um numbers if the numbers are
too hot to believe don't believe them so
there's some reason there why the
inflation is taking place the
overinflated numbers and why they're not
purged on a regular basis I mean once
you start purging on a regular basis
it's like a self-cleaning process that
as you go along it gets better and
better and the task gets easy are and
easier and um as Al mentioned you listen
to all those statistics and then you
look at the town of haris it is no
different than the rest of the state and
I can tell you I looked at 234 towns I
went on their websites I looked at what
they were doing as much as I could find
out and you have a very small percentage
in 100% compliance it's about
34% so looking at the information you
have to start drawing questions
and then you have to end up getting at
the result the more we look at it the
more people look at it the better it
gets and easier to stay up on things
than to catch
up and once you start looking at these
things all of these issues result in a
potential for fraud
nefarious there are people out there
that would just ass soon do those things
I'm not saying that they are I don't
know if they are it's near impossible to
prove but you want to close the doors
and elimate those areas of opportunity
to do things that they shouldn't be
doing but I can tell you when you start
looking at the numbers it's it's it's
questionable you really want to clean
things up and you don't really want to
find that you know in New Hampshire with
the first anation primary we should be
setting example for every other state we
should be proud and transparent what we
do when I look at the
numbers I have to look at it and say
they're unbelievable in kind of relating
to medical terms you would say they're
morbidly obese numbers just for thought
process um there two major problems I'm
on the second major problem major
problem is having a higher uh trangent
population and I have some data that I
looked at in Hollis that really point
out some pretty substantial points of
interest and when you look at the census
and you look at some of the statistics
of the number of multiple family houses
rental units in New Hampshire it's
pretty substantial and it's hard to
differentiate that from all of the
cottages and people living on camps and
lakes and things like that but it's
growing and this is this the a growth
over the past few years from 202 1 uh to
about 2023 it grew about by 35% uh up to
35%
here yeah the number of family units are
uh 689 th000 rental units in the state
and that's going to increase because of
high density housing and so on and that
lends itself to a Trent population and
um having the checkl list purged every
10 years does not help that matter at
all it produces the opportunity for
fraud as I stated I took a look
randomly of four different houses in
Hollis I don't know who lived there I
knew where the addresses were but I
couldn't even tell you what the houses
looked like and if you look at a
person's name and I got the name from
the the voter list and I picked names
like Bon because it's very common
particularly in New Hampshire there lots
of them but when you look at it and you
you pull an address as I did with these
four you see the one name that you
should and you know that that one name
lives at that address but then if you
look at the address and look at how many
other names there you find an abundance
in four names I found 16 errors I didn't
look at 10 names and call it down to the
names that that were problemsome I just
picked them and I in one particular
house it was on um Silver Lake Road very
very busy street small house the
driveway couldn't fit two cars you can't
park on the street there and you look at
it and pick out one name you see a small
house cuz I went on Google Maps and
looked at the house and I found that
there were I think it was six different
people living there with about I think
it was uh five different Sur names so
you can see that there is an inflated
and you know why it's because they're
not being purged I'm not saying there's
anything nefarious going on but you
can't have that in that
people believe in the product that we're
producing which is a clean voting list
so what I'm asking for is that um we
look at the problem we know it exists
and now it's time to fix the problem
because I relate to again if any one of
us were Mor morly obese we'd want to go
on a diet now we don't want to go on a
diet in 2027 we want to start fixing the
problem immediately the sooner we can
fix it the better off it'll be the more
transparent let anyone see the
information
at any time and then we can hang our hat
on and say have with it go
look minimal changes should be seen once
you clean it like I say it's easier to
keep it up than it is to catch up I
think I'll end on that point I had
submitted information you can look at
all my documentation and I'll be very
have questions from the committee
seeing hearing none the thank you so
much I don't have any other pink cards
we had one person signed up who didn't
speak in support by the way it was the
Secretary of State's office
um and online I don't know why I keep
closing the online because I have to
read
it
okay okay
490 now we get to do the weird lookup
here we go all right online there were
eight in support five in opposition no
neutral with that I'm going to close the
public hearing on Senate bill4 490 I'm
going to reopen the public hearing on
Senate bill 530 relative to reports of
receipts and expenditures filed by
political communities of candidates and
C of candidates and and
candidates um only one pink card left
Olivia
zinc miss zincs good to see you good to
see you um good afternoon me uh chairman
Barry and members of the election law
committee uh for the record my name is
Olivia zinc executive director of open
democracy and I live in Franklin and we
do need to reduce the influence of money
and politics and increase the voices of
average everyday Citizen and this bill
provides accountability and transparency
following the December six campaign
Finance reports um it is more clear than
ever that we need um urgent
reform um I took a look at two
governatori candidates so both the
friends of Cindy warmington report and
um the friends of Chuck moris report I'm
just going to hold it up so you can see
the
data I mean you need a magnifying glass
it's um some of them are upside down
they're not even like right side up so
you have to flip them over and upside
down
um so I did take two screenshots due to
the small font on two of the two of the
reports that were just filed on December
6 of
2023 the legislator has a chance to make
sure that campaign Finance reports are
leg legible so that transparency is
critical for
voters um I also want to say that you
could make this bill stronger
on lines three and four and
18 it is just limited to political
Committees of of a candidate and
candidates I um think that this should
be uh the leg uh making sure that
legible reports should be everyone who
files a report not just two classes of
who file a report make them everybody
um and I know that this committee is
looking at moving to the online filing
which I think solves the font size
problem completely so if you do that um
um but I do urge you to ought to pass
before the you know urgently because
then this could fix it for this election
cuz I know those reforms of online
system will not happen until following
elections happy to take any questions
are there questions from the
committee do we do you feel that eighto
sufficient could I sorry I couldn't help
myself don't I couldn't help myself I
could I had to do it I had to do it I
mean the question is I don't know what
what size font this is it looks like
eight font to me uh I also think this is
smaller this might be 4 point
f um I just think they need to be
legible and so I think that the the you
know what the point font is it's up
that's your committee decision but I do
think voters need to be able to read
these and not have a magnifying glass in
order to read these the point of the
these reports are for
transparency and people putting them in
such small fonts um make it so that you
can't read them and one of them is faxed
so this is not only just whatever size
font this is but then it's faxed on top
of it so it's even harder to re read
it fax in that 8 point font you know
what I mean um all right no other
questions from the committee thank you
uh Mr Z and thank you for allowing me to
get my my uh font joke in I had to do it
I did do the full committee reports that
I gave to the clerk if anyone wants to
see the full committee reports instead
of just the um screenshots I took what I
find interesting though is the
expenditure Parts they made larger than
the campaign donations so um they
definitely um looks great I what to talk
about what's the issue here um thank uh
we had two people signed up on the blue
sheet who didn't speak um one of which
was the Secretary of State's office
online there were four in support zero
opposed that that's our last hearing for
today thank you to the committee um try
to get me those reports by the end of
the day otherwise I'll start writing
them um I did get yours and 344 has
already been sent in um so I'm very
proud of myself on that and I will see
Tuesday